three
two
what's up everybody it's hp podcast
friday
june 10th
we have a special episode here today on
this after dark well of course joined by
my wife ela who we love so well thank
you and uh a distinguished guest is with
us here today chelsea manning
thank you for joining us
thank you i'm very you know very
interested in your story and everything
you've done
and i look forward to having a uh
talking about a lot of stuff with you so
thanks for being here nice thanks
um
is it true so let me just
lay some ground work here if if there's
anybody who doesn't know who you are
who's watching
basically you are a
united states government whistleblower
you've blew the whistle on the military
the government and it was the biggest
leak of military documents ever right
almost a million documents or over a
million documents it was 750 000 750 000
yeah yeah
and
well it was you know a huge story all
through i mean it still is right but
like the past decades it's been uh
very present and uh yeah media yeah it's
gotten a little bit of attention you
faced the wrath of of two presidents
maybe more so one than the other yeah
two two presidents technically three
because one was vice president at the
time so
but trump obviously has not had kind
things to say about you
trump hasn't had kind things to say
about me now or anyone really i mean
yeah he does this a lot of government
people hillary even hates his own kids
don't feel too bad yeah
i don't really care i don't care
and
pardoned by obama after seven years well
communicated commuted by oh by obama
after seven years yeah and there's just
so much to talk about i really want to
uh
really want to start from the beginning
but actually before i get started from
the beginning
it is friday so we have to say hello to
uh this is gabe he's known as white claw
gabe he calls in every friday yep he's a
local celebrity around here
gabe how's it
going it's great [ __ ]
it's friday baby
[Music]
i'm chugging a soda oh you got a root
beer no white claws yet
bart's the best [ __ ] okay
the weekend [ __ ] let's [ __ ]
go oh he loves friday he loves the
weekend who doesn't
what's going on with the barks rooper
you're not oh [ __ ] he's chugging it oh
my god oh we got a root beer chug from
gabe
no way dude you are going to be so
[ __ ] up this friday he's dripping
oh my god he's got to get the drips in
wow how was that
no no no no no no
no
games don't do it
oh my god
someone handed gabe another barks root
beer oh he's struggling
from off screen
who is that mysterious yeah someone's
miss gabe is just wow he is going off
this friday
two barks root beer chugs man that is
legendary that counts yeah that one's
clean clean
you know people talk about the sprite
challenge what is that gabe just
is there a third one
yeah don't do it not worth it gabe don't
do a third one
oh wow wow okay
oh my god
[ __ ] baby how's your stomach feeling
after that
much better
[ __ ] baby oh
[Laughter]
all right gabe well you have a great
weekend okay
i gotta talk to my guest but thanks for
checking in
thank you that was quite a show [ __ ]
baby all right you have a great weekend
love you dude
[ __ ]
gabe uh white clock gave everyone that
was an unexpected treat
chugging two barks root beers
first one didn't count that's why
because there was a drip yeah that they
had to do a mull again yeah and you are
you are strict i am strong so it's put
you know it's like in the military
yeah yeah yeah you get you get to into
the 41 club where you don't you know
don't pass your airborne test because
you only reach 42 you're supposed to
reach 42 as a minimum yeah and then the
the instructor whoever is measuring you
just goes 41 41. 41. doesn't count
military [ __ ]
well let's talk let's start from the
beginning okay
so
chelsea you were where were you born uh
so i was born in uh mercy hospital in
oklahoma city oklahoma if you want to
get technical sure i was born in the
midwest yeah i grew up mostly in the
midwest until i was about 11 or 12. um i
think it was 11 whenever i moved out
with my mother because my so i have a my
father is american he was in the navy
and he he lived out in the uk
um on his navy tour uh there and married
my mother
came back they came back to the states
uh she got naturalized here um lived
here for uh
live lived here until i was basically
born with my sister uh and uh yeah
basically spent the first 11 or 12 years
of my life living with her and my sister
and my father until my parents divorced
my sister being 11 years older
moved out of the house and i moved
my mother gained custody of me and i
moved out in the uk uh and went to
school and secondary school in southwest
wales so you're okay so so your your dad
is english or half no no my mother my
mother's my mother's wife okay so you
moved out to to the uk i did interesting
and then and then it came back to the
states after um after a few years i came
back and moved in with my father again
you're a dual citizen uh i am yes okay
very cool yeah that used to get you into
eu it doesn't anymore no it doesn't get
yeah and that i i probably such a bird i
apparently gotta apply for irish
citizenship now oh that will that'll get
you in that'll get me around a little a
little curveball thrown so
how was so basically what was it like
kind of
your your dad was a military man that's
kind of interesting because obviously
you ended up going into the military
he was navy he was a navy guy you were
an army guy yeah
there's a rivalry there yeah i mean you
know basically basically after after um
after my parent after i moved back with
my father um he remarried and uh i was
uh i was a little uh a little different
as a as a kid right because i was like
living as living as this sort of this uh
this like gender non-conforming you know
uh
twinkish boy
boy mode kind of tran you know like i
was i like i i didn't really know that i
was trans like i kind of knew something
was going on but i was just like you
know goth rebellious or whatever um she
did not like me and so uh after i turned
18 and he was no longer
uh
liable you know to legally
to hold me
she basically told him to kick me out of
the house
and i lived uh houseless in basically
the midwest and
landed in chicago for
almost a year
is your dad kind of a traditional guy
like were they accepting of the whole i
think gender confusion i think i think
my father's not so much um uh on the on
the
uh
i would say that my father
uh wasn't homophobic but he was
definitely like on the transphobic
spectrum so just probably like but you
know he's also like this individualist
guy who's just like ah right you know
like uh like you know like a macho yeah
he's just like uh very uh
very much your sort of typical like uh
white upper middle class yeah western
being trans is just like such a foreign
concept yeah probably so you know i
wasn't exactly accepted but you know i
um i i did try you know so my i moved in
with my aunt uh in maryland for
uh you know after after being houseless
in chicago which i just want to mention
real fast you know being out in l.a it's
just like the house well yeah i'm
homeless
that sounds really rough here and
chicago is a cold
[ __ ] like la's like nice you know but
chicago has brutal brutal yeah yeah
so you're you're um your stepmom
was she what was the issue was it like a
transphobic or homophobic yeah i think
so i mean she was definitely homophobic
um traditional like christian oh very
much so okay um although the irony is
that they divorced like a couple years
later oh she's going to help yeah i know
right
see you in hell yeah
so you know uh so yeah basically um you
know didn't have a lot of family support
uh
you know
as it was coming out um but i moved in
with my aunt uh my my father's uh my
father's sister uh in maryland and uh
while i was there i was you know sort of
juggling three jobs trying to pay for
bills you know trying to find my own
place
uh and uh and you know it was like
summer summer 2006
uh into like summer 2007 so about this
year time frame that i was working at
starbucks i was working at i worked at
abercrombie and [ __ ]
wow
oh i um
i was in college college too like so
basically it was like 100 hour a week
100 hour weeks of just doing constant
stuff and this churn and while this is
all going on the iraq war is like the
main thing like like the main like it's
the dinner table discussion it's the
conversation that everybody's having you
know they had the the household names of
george w bush donald rumsfeld um then
robert gates you know and the surge sort
of
all of this stuff happening in the
background
um
while i'm also just sort of like
struggling to figure out who i am where
i fit in the world how i you know where
where do i go where do i land
essentially
um in you know going uh going forward
with my life and you know fitting in and
uh and i started wreaking i was trying
to reconnect with my father in this time
and he kept on pushing me to go you know
into the uh going to the navy or the air
force i see and of course me being a
rebellious
uh pain in the ass uh you know kid i i
enlisted in the army uh and i also knew
that you know this troop surge was going
on so the army was where you know people
were needed so i enlisted in the army so
actually before i get too deep into that
i want to go back to so you were living
in chicago you were homeless in chicago
yes and for how long did you live in
chicago
um i'm i've been i haven't really done
the math on it but you know several
months so and were you living on the
street like streaming uh i had
i
borrowed uh my father's pickup truck
okay so i was in a nissan i was in a red
1992 nissan hard body pickup and was it
like a winter thing or a summer
thankfully the winter hadn't hit but
there were cold nights yeah yeah but the
worst was the hot days right in that
time frame so what did you do kind of
what were you doing during that time you
were you ran kind of
got kicked out of your house by your
stepmom yeah and then why did you decide
to go to chicago um well i've it felt
the safest um because i tried a couple
different cities um i had been i had
dealt with sort of tout like small town
sheriffs tulsa police department you
know st louis police department i dealt
with sort of like being a houseless
person not being able to find a place to
sleep
uh and basically being harassed by cops
all the time so when you say safest you
mean that like chicago has the most
i wasn't even
yeah they didn't they didn't [ __ ] with
me like i could sleep somewhere and you
know i could sleep in my truck and not
be bothered for most nights i see i see
um
and so after living there for a couple
months
you basically i i do want to say what i
was doing uh i i had a job at the guitar
center okay do you play
i was at the i was in pro audio so i was
that's my dj hell yeah dude
my uh my one of my side gigs is uh djing
oh right so are you are you getting back
into djing at all the people are
wondering yeah i uh i've i got my uh i
got my xdj so um and i'm working on my
set so at some point going to
surprise someone somewhere so when you
dj are you mixing new things are you
just playing i'm sticking to i'm
sticking to a playlist right now um but
uh it's not gonna be completely
pre-programmed but you know like i'm i'm
playing around with sort of um you know
doing live production
um pads and additional like things with
with uh with synthesizers that i can
attach to it you know just sort of mix
it up and do sort of bootlegs but
interesting
that was what i did in like mid
or you know later that uh when i was
living the whenever i was living in um
maryland uh i went and i did the dc club
scene and you know played the oh play a
couple sets
mostly like mostly to like university of
maryland and georgetown students that's
a that's not a bad gig though they pay
you oh yeah i got paid but you know it
wasn't enough to like pay the bills yeah
it was a semi-professional best so when
you're living in chicago how do you like
shower and kind of just take care of
yourself and all that kind of stuff if
you're living out of your car truck stop
truck stops yeah because i had a truck
so i'd spend an enormous amount of gas
money driving out to a truck stop
using a truck stop uh like shower like
uh
what is it the flying j they usually
have showers or they had them back then
so they still do dan dan dan you
showered at the flying j on a road trip
or two yeah uh that's interesting i've
never i didn't even know they had
showers at trucks yeah either do you pay
or is it just open it should uh if i
recall being open so um i'm not
i mean they have a private stall it's
yeah is it kind of shady like it's like
a pool
wow
that's very progressive for this country
yeah well
you know i'm surprised it wasn't the
best but it was certainly it was you
know it was certainly uh
the ability to have some amount of
hygiene yeah that's good or or you know
uh the other thing was just sort of like
uh and i talked about more more about
this in the my book sort of survival
strategies in terms of city like you
know surviving you know finding food
this is what apparently it looks like
that's that looks nice damn that's i
don't remember looking nice one right i
don't remember that looking like yeah
that looks like a nice gym that's that's
great
how could you keep it that clean out of
public truck stop there's no way
it's a tiny towel
well i guess it's a makeshif it's one
it's in between let's let's go
so anyway
so okay so you're there so you're living
in uh chicago so what makes you decide
you're gonna move to maryland so my aunt
tracked me down i don't know how um
interesting you've been trying to try to
work out work out exactly what happened
but my aunt your dad's uh sister dad's
sister who lives in this
you know she says it's a oh she says
it's a nice house and it's an okay house
but it's a beautiful house and it's a
it's a lovely house in maryland good for
her yeah um and so yeah so she had a bit
of space for me and i crashed there how
did she track you down though i don't
know uh you know there's been a just
when we were sort of doing research for
the book you know it was uh we were
trying to figure out piece of pieces
together because i just remember like
on my phone being on my phone one day
because i had
things that i had were a cell phone i
had a laptop
i had uh and i could do wi-fi at some
places
and i had and i had my truck so
um you know and i and i tried to get a
like a like a post office box situation
as well
and uh so i was you know trying to
establish myself i was actually looking
for looking to get an apartment in uh
like like um northern chicago uh you
know the i'm a cubs fan yeah
i'm sticking to northern chicago um but
yeah i wanted to stay
i wanted to sort of settle down there
and my aunt called me and just rang me
on the phone and
i was just like she said hey come live
with me yeah i don't have money and
she's like well i'll send you money and
she sent me enough gas money that's very
sweet yeah
lifesaver was she close were you close
with her before absolutely
yeah that's sweet god bless god bless
you yeah man
incredible is an incredible and very
generous person
wow that's touching that's really nice
to hear yeah so you moved down into
maryland with your with your aunt and
then how long are you living there for
uh almost a year um before i enlist in
the military so what my aunt was not
happy about right is she kind of more
liberal version of like your dad yeah
more progressive hates the military yeah
she was a she was a john edwards uh like
supporter and then uh john kerry
supporter uh and then uh obama like uh i
think she was clinton and then obama
supporter in 2008 so liberal down the
line yeah she's definitely very you know
centrist democratic got it
is your dad kind of a trump guy is that
what where his politics i don't know i
haven't talked to my dad in over a
decade okay i don't know okay
interesting
uh i think the last time i spoke to my
dad was in 2010 so that's interesting i
was curious how he was
i don't know i let my uh my sister is
the buffer okay okay
well we'll get we'll get to that we have
a long way to cover yeah so you live
with your aunt
you were still in touch with your dad at
the time iraq's going on and said now
you said i wanted to join the army
because that's where they needed people
were were you fulfilling some kind of
patriotic duty
i think so i you know um i didn't have
strong political i didn't have a lot of
political underpinning um at that age uh
i i often like to joke that uh in 2007
my politics consisted of uh leave
brittany alone okay
and they and you know what's interesting
about the league brittany uh
as well they were right you guys were
right we all made fun of you and you
guys were right god damn it yeah so that
was the extent of my politics in 2007.
how old were you when you enlisted in
there i was 18. i think it was no it's
19. it was 19. because i was 2007. so
was it kind of just the typical military
trap where you're like i don't know what
to do and the military sounds like a
good place to go yeah i think so um yeah
you know uh and and you know the uh it
was everywhere like you know the ads
were constant uh the army strong yeah it
was really attractive for somebody sort
of you know needing to find you know
because like i felt lost at you know at
19 years old i had been houseless um i
was struggling with all these different
things um and i just really didn't have
didn't really have a sense of like where
i fit in the world and and then you know
i was like struggling with being i i was
i figured out by the time i was like 19
though that you know like hey like maybe
i need to like see hormones or get some
kind of you know interesting uh therapy
or something like that and uh and you
know my father was just pushing me to
man up like
and i did
you know i did at that age still want to
like
get my you know get my family's favor
back you know so
so by the time you enlisted were you
kind of
did you you were somewhat aware that you
were trans i i i i knew i was gay
because i was definitely you were living
as a guest
yeah i was uh i was in the dc uh i was
in the chicago and then the dc gay scene
uh were you closeted though to your
family at that time or you were out uh i
mean i didn't exactly come out but uh i
mean it wasn't hiding it you know yeah
yeah
me coming home with like a rainbow belt
okay on fried weekend got it yeah
okay
so
enrolling in the military were you
somewhat afraid because you're living as
a gay man and you think you might be
trans were you afraid of what it would
be like to live in the military with
that identity no no i i had no idea what
the real consequences of that i see i
see you know uh i you know so i went to
basic training and uh enlisted as an
analyst so i became an intelligence
analyst and i worked in that uh sort of
you know it's funny
um i became uh i became an intelligence
analyst because i didn't want to get
like because like i work with computers
and i have a background i've always had
a computer
that was like seven years old that had
like i've had this you know like rig in
my apartment in my in my bedroom right
my own computer which you know like out
like being like seven or eight years old
having a having a computer with internet
access and it's like everything the mid
90s was just like you know something
that most people didn't have access to
um and uh
and yeah so i've always you know i i
have an affinity with computers and i've
always worked with computers but
actually i actually wanted to be a be in
a role that was more like about
geopolitics sort of thinking about
things tactics strategy
understanding of people um
and uh sort of uh the the military has
this phrase human terrain understanding
the human terrain especially in
counter-insurgency operations um and uh
and that's what i wanted to do and i
wanted to get into that and then the
first thing i do whenever i finish
training they hand me over this gigantic
data science rig which is you know
computer system and databases and i'm
just like oh no
why why were you like oh no because i
was like i'm gonna get in trouble
because you knew you were going to
misuse the deck
i mean well you can't help it right you
know was it like a super computer at the
time just like a super gnarly how was it
it was it del alienware yeah
you're saying yeah well so so
you enlist you do how was boot camp for
you i mean just right out the gate
because how long i think basic training
i had yeah i had nervous i had like some
a nerve injury on my right arm and left
foot
um i talked about it more in the book uh
you know there's the plug right there
hey guys there's a book coming out for
sure
book is coming out something to look
forward to towards the end of the year
working on the title i think it's re i
think it's readme i think that's going
to be the title read me yeah it's a
command yeah
yeah it's also like it's an important
thing because there's like a file in
it's about double yeah
uh but yeah like uh
yeah so basically uh i
you know i i was i was working with
computers and doing data science and um
and that was my role and that was what i
did did they ask you what kind of role
do you want or did it happen so you get
to pick your military occupational
specialty or mos
before you enlist in the army not the
same with other services i don't know if
it's changed or anything but at the time
the army was where you went to sign up
and know the role that you were going to
be put in that's interesting can you
just sign up for whatever you want or do
you do you have to take some aptitude
test yeah i took an aptitude test and i
slam dunked it apparently you're a
smartie for the army i mean apparently
like i i don't know i and i haven't
looked at it but basically i was like i
want to be i want to do this and like
you have to pass this test i'm like okay
like did i pass i'm like yes
okay because i would assume that the
analyst is one of the more
probably yeah i remember i remember the
only one that had i think that one of
the ones that had more aptitude was like
was like satellite communications
federalist wow very specific yeah
yeah but so the analyst basically is
someone
it's an it's a part of the intelligence
branch right yeah it's the by definition
yeah and you crunch
basically
data
to we google we you google [ __ ] is that
right well it's it's you know we do what
google does which is just collect data
and do analysis right so you get a bunch
of data from the military and basically
they say let me just do math
oh it's math yeah it's math
can you give me an example
all right now we're getting into machine
learning which is my specialty okay uh
there is a number of different means and
methods in uh in data science um one of
which which was extremely popular at the
time because this is this is before you
know you had your uh you had your nvidia
graphics card in your machine
and you could do neural networks or
anything kind of more advanced machine
learning at the time
you can use bayesian statistics which
you know still requires a lot of
number crunching and
it it'll it uses a specific set of
addition and addition instructions
on something that is predictable
and it allows you to take a historical
data set
and
move it forward into the future
and look at what's possible in the
future through a certain amount of
through a certain amount of time so but
like what kind of stuff would you would
you put in there or like it could be
anything i mean you know uh if you know
stock tips you want to put stock you
know you want to put the stock market in
into there that's how the early the
earliest stock the stock market models
were but i mean like in any rack what
was like the most common thing that you
would like how does that yeah i'm not
yeah well i mean i can't get into the
specific data but um generally it's you
know it's people places locations times
like you know like certain certain
products you just try to find patterns
yeah there's a pattern now pattern
analysis okay okay i see but um you know
and interesting now i do now i do this
for a living still yeah they'll do the
same thing
it seems like so
did you it sounds like you got an
extensive education in the army is that
uh accurate because it's well i mean
school in the uk which helps yeah so you
already had been to college
um no i i essentially the the last two
years of school in the uk sixth form are
the equivalent to the first two years of
u.s college education okay so yeah and
then i had an a third year and then i
had a third year so i don't have a
degree but i have a lot of college
credits got it so um you know and now i
don't even don't need to bother yeah
yeah yeah so
you went to boot camp
you sustained some kind of injuries
uh yeah some kind of nerve injury i
still don't know what it is this day
i've had i've had i've had it looked at
and whatever and um you know
it didn't disqualify me from trying
again so i just had issues with sort of
the first few weeks of basic training
they held me back for a few weeks okay
um and then i waited until i healed up
and got a good
sign off good to go and i went back and
no no no problems second how was the
basic how was the boot camp for you
uh i mean so long ago right um i think
you know i mean obviously the first the
first few weeks were tough because it
was like i was like
my my arm's not working i can't do a
push-up right you know it's just like
you know you can't do a push-up you're
in basic training like that's kind of
the point of face of training uh but
yeah once i got but once i got and
actually saw like a doctor was like yeah
there's an issue here like we need to
like look into it um then then then it
was smooth sailing for me i basically
fit in and did you find camaraderie
there amongst the i did yeah yeah i did
um i think i think one of the most
fascinating things about sort of
indoctrination to the military is
um
you know you get because i i wasn't from
you know like my father was in the navy
but like i didn't really know much about
the military but once i got in once i
was sort of
brought into uh military culture and
started to understand it i've always
felt sort of um i've i find that in
institutional environments now and this
this goes with prison as well and jails
and jails and being houseless as well i
found that in in institutional
environments i find that i bond with
people very quickly and i sort of start
to learn sort of the you know rules
expectations roles that you you know
that you sort of fit in um in these
kinds of environments um you know
sometimes harsh environments and yeah
you know i find i make friends very
quickly i've made connections very
quickly i i develop trust and rapport
with people very quickly so yeah i you
know i felt throughout my time in the
military i felt you know close to people
i can't relate to that i did too yeah
because i did the army in israel
and um
in boot camp i remember like getting
really close group of friends yeah
you're around you're on each other 12 14
hours a day and it's like people who
maybe in outside of it you would never
become friends but when you're put in
that situation
you kind of like
develop that bond yeah it's a it's a
bond it's hard to describe yeah like
a you know sort of a camaraderie
kinship i guess the reason i ask is
because you were living as a gay man i
wasn't sure how the army was accepting
of that were you closeted at the time i
was just kind of don't ask don't tell
don't ask don't tell at this time um
i mean
i would say 2008 when i before before
before i went over into iraq
um in 2009 i would say that uh i've
started started to become more aware
of the idea that there might be a period
of time in which there isn't a don't ask
don't tell and which i don't have to
hide this from my uh you know because it
seems silly to like hide something that
everybody everybody knew ever okay so it
wasn't like it was not as serious in
2008 as it was in the 90s
that was my sense and i and i was in a
non-sort of combat role yeah it wasn't
like i was
i wasn't a dark kicker i was a number
cruncher yeah so i i got the sense that
um that i that i was pretty and you know
and this is the intelligence field at at
least in
our unit we were 60 female so
you know like this is a this is this is
again oh is that infantry you know it's
not ground pounder so most of your
colleagues when you went to iraq and
actually started doing the the analyzing
were women yes it was uh it was it was
it was primarily like women were the
majority in my office um and so yeah i i
got the sense that nobody cared
well that's that's great but uh trans
stuff was a different matter i started
that and that started to kick in for me
um while i was while i was deployed i
was like you know because i was i was
doing things like cross-dressing and
you know trying to explore this uh new
thing um quite a bit uh more and uh and
that that was uh that was it that was a
bit more difficult you couldn't get
around that no one that one was not
people were not understanding and i
think that was where i started to feel
more of frustration more sort of
distance and more alienation i think
during around that time it's funny you
go well you know being being homosexuals
more accepted understood and i think at
the same time this issue of being trans
was probably
a really new conversation and i don't
think people
i think they've come a long way i think
people there's like insane amounts of
transphobia in the world that's
disgusting yeah well you know like i
often i have to remind people like in
2010 like nobody was talking about this
stuff yeah exactly and then i came out
of prison in 2017 and it's like the main
issue that people want to talk about and
now in 2022 like i just want people to
shut up about it really please please
leave us alone we do not do that we i
mean you know like
you know whatever they of course you
know they they're like oh yeah you want
to recruit people well guess what yeah i
kind of do i'm like i'm coming for you
oh yeah we're coming for you
yeah we're coming we're coming for you
we're gonna they're gonna
yeah yeah guess what we are we'll see
mailings i mean you know this goes back
to hari milk you know like harvey milk
you know like his his whole pitch you
know running running for supervisor in
san francisco was
my name is harvey milk and i'm here to
recruit you so uh yeah
i'm here to recruit you there you go
well it's a glamorous lifestyle and
everybody loves you for being trans yeah
it's hard yeah and you get you get to
take you get to take these nice pretty
pills yeah
so okay so we're in boot camp things are
going pretty good and then how long are
you in boot camp and then you get get
before you get deployed to iraq oh it
wasn't so um i mean boot camp is a navy
term okay it's a navy marine corps what
would i what are you doing what is it uh
it's basic training basic training basic
training basic yeah um a little little
terminology correction there for for the
for the military
graphics yes yes um but yeah like um
but yeah so i actually spent uh about a
year uh with my unit in uh in upstate
new york fort drum new york um
that was what i was attached to
um
and uh and i just did just to like watch
the canadian border type stuff
just
make sure that you know
canadians aren't invading they don't
care they're damn it yeah so uh
uh the
our mission was uh homeland security
i see a role for a year and then we went
and uh we actually were actually we're
actually supposed to go to afghanistan
in
2000 uh
december 2009 was we were originally
slated to go to afghanistan
but the obama administration shifted
over a few units and moved things around
to cause a surge in afghanistan uh go
leading into 2010 and 2011 so this is a
shift of resources from iraq which was
drawing down and moving to afghanistan
so we actually got bumped up on the sk
on the calendar to i think september or
october of 2009 and then we had our
theater change so then we had all this
work that i'd done for a year
pre-deployment for afghanistan was
thrown away
and uh and it's like oh just kidding
like you're going to iraq and you're
going to iraq like in three months so
how does that happen they're like hey
just someone comes and they're like all
right you have three months and we're
going to arrest yeah this is this is big
this is big thing in the military call
or the army called the past chart it's
like where the where the big divisions
and brigade combat teams are and at
least in the time this time frame and so
it would you would see like the patches
of the different units
and the numbers and it would be like a
different point to time where they were
and it would be shifted over but yeah
you you would check the past chart if
you wanted to know when you were
deploying it only certain people even
knew like the time frame it was like you
know it was
the the troop movements tend to be you
know uh secret though
when you're in the army do you go back
home
every weekend or how does it work
overseas
not uh not at all
that one year yeah i went i went on i
went i went at home for the weekend i
mean i lived i lived upstate new york
which you know it was a drive drive down
to maryland right it's not too far
six hours so yeah i could do we we had
for three or four day weekends we had
weekend passes
uh i on multiple occasions definitely
violated the 75 mile rule you can't
leave you can't go within 75 miles yeah
you can't go you can't leave uh 75 miles
of a base at least at fort drum uh in
2009 and uh and i did i went down to
maryland for the weekend sometimes
why is that just for army readiness yeah
probably yeah yeah yeah i think i think
it's 50 i think it's typically 50 50
miles for most bases but yeah
so you get deployed to
iraq are you nervous to go yeah i mean
i'm a big ideal you're right i'm excited
you want to work you want to yeah you
know like i enlisted obviously
with the intention of
the troop search and being involved in
that and it sort of didn't pan out that
i was going to be there but uh i was
excited i was ready to do my job i was
super happy thrilled to finally
do what i had trained to do what i was
preparing to do what i'd spent
a year of my life preparing for you know
in terms of doing my work and being very
prepared for it and uh and genuinely
being excited and i i hit the ground
running really
that's interesting so
by the way how do they fly you over
there do they have their own charted
army planes yeah so you do i see
something they fly just coach yeah
basically they just uh they just take
they just take like a delta plane and
they just they're like oh for real yeah
they they contract out like uh airlines
uh and just say like the you know
the pilots or delta or really united or
american uh american airlines and then
you're the the um stewardess or the the
um the flight attendants are
uh that that as well uh it's just like
and then it's just us with our right so
it's all it's all military the whole
thing yeah and you still get the
officers get the first class upstairs
of course and they still serve you
peanuts and all that stuff and what it's
like a normal play yeah it's like a
normal flight except what happened wow
that's very interesting
actually i actually have a picture i
have this funny picture that i that i
have uh even to this day uh where i i
took a picture of of uh of uh it was my
uh
it was my m16 or i am sorry my m4 and my
m4 is just like sitting there with like
with like the the optic and it's sitting
in my chair and it's like like in in
like a plane i'm just like tsa is really
like letting their car
okay so we land in iraq do you go with
your team
from before or is it about we just split
up a little bit to shift everything over
yeah some people yes yeah so like you
know there's like the torch party and
there's like the pre-party and then
there's the main body and then there's
little stragglers
i see so you you land and then like how
quickly do you have to like a big travel
to go to your new base
yeah yeah like and i was like very very
movie right you know you're
you get you you get into a c-130 and
then you get off the c-130 you go into
you know you're processed in and what's
the c-130 like a armored vehicle no
c-130 is uh c130 rolling down the strip
it's a plane you know oh it's a player
it's the airborne plane it's the plane
that you know people jump out out of is
that the one we that biden was in dan i
think it was a c-17 oh
okay so you land at the airport you get
on a new plane one of these big fly
okay this with the i say i see i see
wait is that a c-130 yeah that's a c-130
it's like open on this side
yeah some of those are ac-130s which
those are the ones that have like they
actually have like a howitzer like on
the side that shoots
it's like a big cargo plane for people
to parachute out of but obviously you
didn't do that no we didn't jump
no we didn't jump out of it but uh yeah
we landed but it was a combat landing so
it's like you're
your stomach goes up near your chest
what does that mean
it's like you know it's like a it's like
you're on a roller coaster like oh
really
that's like straight down oh my god
they're doing that to like evade yeah
because yeah you know it's a war zone i
see so just to lessen their descent area
really wow interesting yeah uh but yeah
you know and then uh and then we took a
helicopter out to our uh remote base in
east you know east of baghdad eastern
magna interesting so it was remote was
there like a military prison or was it
kind of a secret thing
uh oh the base yeah yeah so yeah it was
it was remote it was a hammer uh which
is uh
30 kilometers
east of the of the main part of eastern
baghdad so
nothing around
if you're just crunching numbers why why
the remote base uh
the
for the draw down uh one of the
agreements for the drawdown was to
reduce the number of um the number of uh
bases and positions in the cities i see
so you were
you were uh part of a dwindling force
yes of uh u.s military yeah we were
going home
was that odd for you to be flying into
iraq as everyone's leaving
uh well no because it was it was it
wasn't clear that we were leaving at
that time
um
so
there was a debate about it like
obviously part of the drawdown was leave
the cities obama had said that you know
he had set a timetable was actually the
bush administration's timetable for
leaving uh for the withdrawal and that
which then became obama's timetable
right um and so you know
we
it it looked like we might be but we
also were hedging
sort of like okay what if we need to
bring back more and then like i remember
there was still construction going on
okay even while we were talking about
leaving
so very much one foot in one foot out
yeah yeah i see yeah so you're stationed
here so how many people are you
basically stationed with uh
wow um
i think it was i don't remember the
numbers but it was at least 1500 in the
basement well how many people did you
have like an immediate working with is
that big to you 1500 sounds like cool
yeah it was
it was
medium sized yeah um but yeah and u.s
military is big yeah i mean my base had
maybe like 40 people yeah that was the
number of people in my office it was
very small there were people in my
office like 40.
the number of people and they were all
analysts or they're doing all kinds of
different stuff analysts yeah different
different different roles is your work
collaborative or is it kind of just like
a wolf solo wolf stuff we were work
group style baby we were we were doing
the we were doing the silicon valley uh
um
working group
interesting yeah from that time we were
doing the the lean
sort of lean uh office type environment
where you know rotating roles and
um
you know like you you would have a diff
you'd have different roles at different
times it was it doesn't make a lot of
sense because like the rest of the
military is very hierarchy it's very
hierarchy right it's just like you're
you are
you know you like you you're you have a
captain who
has a first sergeant who has a staff
sergeant yeah or or a mat or or you know
some some uh you know like uh
or some sergeant or whatever who goes
down the corporal and goes down to the
privates right and no it was not like
that it was very fluid you know
everybody sort of had their different
positions and roles it was a bit more
horizontal and a bit more fluid in terms
of like the actual work because it's a
bottom-up sort of structure the intel
intelligence work is stuff that comes in
and then is brought up and you know uh
um presented to the the staff officers
interesting you know the staff officers
being you know your
um your commander their exo
their administrative officer their
intelligence officer their operations
officer their supply officer etc
legal
okay so you're you're basically working
with a bunch of analysts and basically
at what point do you start thinking like
you know start having kind of like
gender gender
wow this is this has been ongoing this
is this has never stopped but it's it
you had mentioned that it got really bad
when you were deployed yeah yeah yeah
yeah definitely
yeah i it was definitely becoming more
marketed and more of a significant uh
sort of
thing as i was you know and and then it
continued on because like uh i don't
we're not going to get into the 20 into
the 2010 leaks themselves but um we
started it but i i so i got arrested
obviously for a big leak
um
which the contents of which i cannot
discuss sure um under non-disclosure
agreement existing to this day from
2007. um
which has made writing a book very
difficult as you can imagine yeah uh you
know uh getting it through the the
publication process was uh has has
caused a significant amount of delay um
we did go to the government for
permission because we don't want to get
sued out into oblivion
and unlike you know someone like er like
edward snowden uh who you know lives in
russia i live in the united states and i
have to pay taxes right
i've got the irs so i gotta i you know i
i can't i can't play around um
so yeah we've been very careful with
with sort of uh writing the book but uh
but yeah by the time i got into the
prison system
um it was clear like i was like yes this
is this is
this is important to me i'm trans
interested i know what i need um but by
that time it was you know the lawyers
basically written it off as like too
late uh for me to sort of like seek that
but i didn't give up and so
you know i went through this long court
martial process and basically and i
waited until after that court martial
process because it was just so intense
because it was literally a
year it was a three and a half year long
process through the court system you
know the military court system our dog
just did a big old puke
nice
that's a good
that's some chunks
yeah he has a puking problem he pukes
all the time poor boy
ah so so what something striking about
your story is actually you were the
first
uh
military person to undergo
like hormone therapy yeah and stuff like
that so i mean that's that's very
interesting yeah at least at least with
it with approval people have been taking
like this
first acknowledged person yeah by the
way
especially especially guys taking extra
testosterone yeah definitely yeah okay
of course yeah but uh yeah and there
have been trans you know
i i remember there's actually a story of
a trans person who enlisted who enlisted
in the military and uh man and just
while going through a unit transition
just like
made just said that there was a gender
marker mistake in their paperwork and
then somebody just like clicked a button
and they just got it done wow
and they got away with it for like a
year wow crazy
wow
so for example
uh do you get like they have like the
male uniform and the female uniform yeah
it was yeah yeah were you very gendered
existence was that difficult for you at
the time there or
in prison it became like
it became very important like for to for
the prison to enforce
and we were uh i i had um the american
civil liberties union uh chase strangio
uh fantastic attorney and a fantastic
advocate to this day on trans issues um
fighting lots and lots of legal battles
uh all the way up to the supreme court
in some cases on a regular basis uh
including many of these like [ __ ]
laws that keep that keep getting
proposed and passed in uh in like the
state houses um
and uh but yeah he was my attorney and
uh you know we we we like fought on all
these different nitpicky little
regulations and things together that's
incredible one of the things that we
lost that we never went on until i until
i was released and it was the day that i
was released was like the day that i
stopped cutting my hair because they did
not light up on the hair they're like
you can get hormones we can give you
makeup we can give you all these
different things we can give you all
these things but hair no they would just
did not want to relent on hair well
women in the military can grow their
hair right yeah and so
670-1 baby is that the code what's the
code is there like a length regulation
there's a whole regulation it changes
everything so why do you think it was
that they were stuck on that one yeah we
have no idea interesting it's uh
the all they had to do was was do a
one-page exception of policy and they
just would not relent i would think
makeup would be more of a so that's what
we thought right yeah we did we expected
to not get makeup and to get the hair
do you think it was a spite thing or
just a weird bureaucracy thing i i don't
know maybe they're worried about court
cases and sort of because they have they
have a prison system military has a
prison system and i think they might
have been worried about uh
about different uh religious groups in
prison wanting their hair extensions
okay they thought it maybe it was a
if they were one and yeah yeah right so
yeah it was it wasn't so much spite with
me as spite against like a lot a whole
host of different groups of people i see
just generals right
so i want to ask you more about your
time in iraq but if just if feel free if
i ask a question that you can't answer
just let me know yeah i mean you know
just like it's just dark it's this dark
period of time and now it's even darker
it is why
i mean i i feel like you know i feel
like the us is uh you know the us is
going through uh it's going through
it's going through some things going
through a time period you know and
actually the my whole life experience um
you know uh everything was like you know
like i went from like 2010
and you know being like free out that
was the last time i was like freaking
out um before i went into the
uh
that back well not even that like you
know uh deployed
returning to my deployment and then
going to prison and then coming out in
in 2017 and
um yeah it was like i was like oh shoot
stuff is about to go down here like that
vibe like it was immediate like i went
through like a three day three or four
day cool down period
you know kind of like just sort of like
getting a sense of like okay like
you know because i remember the first
time i looked at an iphone right you
know it's not that i didn't know how to
use it it was that was like my my brain
was like fried by the by the sort of
instant
like deluge of information right from it
and like even like the the the sort of
super small pixels on the screen just
for like we're like wow this is like
this is like making my eyes hurt um so
actually like i needed like a cool down
period of like a few days um but yeah as
soon as i got out uh i was like oh
this is different the vibe is different
the vibes are off it's sort of the
boiling frog is that the sense that i
got it's like this is abram like because
like trump trump had been elected the
year before
um there was the whole election cycle
before that
um you know you this this was
post-occupy post-ferguson you know the
uh militarization of the police
um the sort of rise of right-wing
extremism
um charlottesville happened only a few
weeks after yeah that was a that was uh
that wasn't that crazy and i had friends
who i and i had friends who you know
were out there protesting right you went
into prison obama was president you came
out trump was president yeah so that
that was probably
yeah it might actually one of the one of
the most alarming part parts of my whole
life story is the fact that like i spent
as i i i obama commuted me at the end of
at the end of his term but he commuted
me to time served plus 120 days
so
i had 117 days of the trump
administration i was like oh boy you
thought he might take he might [ __ ] with
you i mean it hadn't happened but this
was a this was definitely scary
well you were facing thirty your full
term was like 35 years yeah it was 35
years i got i got sentenced to 35 years
so i got 28 20 years like cut off
and if you but also the thought of
facing down another 28 years if trump
decided to try to do something well yeah
i was like i was like and i honest
honestly
until the day i was released like the
morning the morning that i was like in
upstate new york like
okay i'm out
um
was uh i was like this isn't happening
right right right that's crazy i
remember i remember that like i remember
i went through this whole process and
actually needed therapy over this which
was like sort of like because like when
you're when you're given a 35-year
sentence yeah
and you've had time to digest that
seven years is pretty half the amount of
time oh yeah you've had time to digest
that
you're like okay this is this is this is
it this is happening you write all that
off
in your brain so like the idea that i
was going to be let out and be like i'll
be opening up a credit card you know
opening up a credit card balance or
buying or renting an apartment or paying
bills
just just weird surreal yeah just so far
it was so far away that you know i just
didn't even think about it or didn't
even worry about it and i just wrote it
off and then to have that be returned to
me was actually a shock to my system and
that that's that i think is in my
opinion that's sort of the definition of
institutionalization is whenever you
have accepted sort of that you know like
your most of your adult life is written
off right you have plenty of time to you
know
screw around in prison and play vid you
know or play uh uh play dungeons and
dragons and and dice dice games is that
what you did in prison i did yes oh it
doesn't sound that bad when you put it
that way did you have good friends like
i did yeah i had i had a lot of friends
in prison um you know uh you know you
again you know institutional environment
you develop camaraderie make friends
yeah um i i connected really well with
the people that i was that i was there
with um we had one very simple an
important role in prison which was don't
ask anybody what the crime is and don't
look into it oh for real you don't want
to know
oh that's really interesting but
everyone probably know who you were
right yeah i was yeah yeah it didn't
matter were you given a chance to
wrap things up say goodbye no i was
to your fellow it was an idiot yeah oh
wow yeah they took me they're like we're
not like but you knew the day was coming
i knew the day was coming but they put
they put me in they put me in a separate
unit immediately when the commun yeah
they saw it on t like the prison staffs
done on t like it's in my book like a
whole story about it but like they were
they saw it on tv and they're like oh
you're going you're we're putting you
aside why'd they do that
uh i think they just didn't want
anything bad to happen to me in the
meantime
like anything interesting an injury in
the workshop if only epstein's prison
guards were as careful
yeah yeah oh yeah it's super suspicious
that's pretty interesting
how they i want to be i want i have
opinions on that okay somebody's been
incarcerated in the in both both the
military and the federal and the city
and i mean you were a high priority
prisoner but jeffrey epstein
was a very high priority prisoner yeah
we can do an aside here what do you
think about that whole sh thing about
how murder yeah murder you do
that's that's that's how a person murder
happens i've i know when it happens i'm
not gonna say i'm not gonna say like
some of the sad stories from prison
where we know bad stuff happened because
like you know it's like how do you prove
it as an inmate but um and some of these
stories are my book um and uh but yeah
like definitely because it's like super
like it's definitely like oh yeah i'm
just like that's suspicious the cameras
you want to get rid of somebody in
prison that's how you do it the guards
do that kind of thing
that's all they do they just [ __ ] with
people yeah they [ __ ] with people i mean
yeah imagine this imagine you're sitting
there and your job is to is to watch
inmates for 12 hours and you're just
sitting there
or tossing your piece of paper or
whatever like of course you're going to
screw with us like we're
we're like and we're not and like nobody
you know nobody listens to inmates no
but you know um i want to say this real
fast because i'm then i'm really
passionate about this and that is um you
know i've i've been asked a little you
know people ask me often ask me a lot
was it scary being in prison or you know
like like you know how how were people
in prison and i just got to say this
time and time again the most violent and
dangerous people in prison
without question were prison guards
every single time and this was military
civilian
state federal
just endless amounts of uh
fear and anxiety of the arbitrariness
and and the uh the the sort of
lack of expectatio of consistent
expectations of what a co or a prison
guard or or somebody who's watching or a
correctional uh officer of any of any
variety was going to do
um and the senior staff as well and uh
and you know it's like it's like it
haunts me to this day because like i you
know i don't associate like somebody
who's like in a prison uniform with with
like a threat whereas like i see
somebody like in a in in a in a co
uniform and i'm like you have a little
trauma left over oh yeah definitely so
sad
do you think it attracts sickos who like
power absolutely that's what it is and
it's even worse than being in some in
some respects i think it's actually
worse than being like a regular cop
because at least a regular cop gets like
carry a gun right they're sort of like
the the second thought like they're the
they're the sort of like after thought
sort of cops right was there any kind of
norm was there
normal prison guards or was it just an
accepted culture of like these are our
objects to [ __ ] with and do what we want
i would say that it's that they're that
it's a rule of thirds which is pretty
consistent with what i've seen in other
in other institutions um
so there is uh there there are the
prison guards who
are goody two shoes they care about
their job they really
um they they really think that they're
doing a good they're doing a service or
whatever and they're fair to you guys
and they try to be fair okay um they
they're that's a high attrition rate
that's a fast turnover rate right that
makes sense yeah then there's the then
the there's the prison guards who um
who look the other way at the bad apples
right okay they're like i'm just doing a
job i'm cutting a paycheck
um you know i don't i i
hear no evil see no they're not sadistic
they just they're just here to work
right but if they see something that's
that's sketchy they will look the other
way right yeah and then there's the then
there's the people who are absolutely
sadistic they will do the worst kinds of
things they'll play games they will lie
they will cheat they will steal they'll
they're just and they get away with it
and nobody will question and then it's
the other and then the worst part is
that that other third of people who look
the other way just you know don't do
anything and they don't say anything so
when when there's like a really sick
prison guard
um
does anything ever happen to them
ever
very rarely i've never seen it i've i've
i've only never seen people retaliated
against for reporting it too and that
includes uh others other guards well
that happens in the police as well yeah
normally the same please it's the same
the blue wall of silence kind of thing
is what was the most uh f'ed up thing
that you saw prison guard duty in my
book okay
it's it's how about the second one then
uh second darkest thing second darkest
thing um that i've seen in uh in prison
guards do um
uh
well it's not it's not one thing but
like it's just neglect of of people with
mental health issues right people who
people say i'm in it i like
a person having a mental health crisis
saying
i'm having a dark time
i'm i'm have i'm not doing so good right
now i need to see somebody and the just
absolute like disgust or
um disregard and then placing that
person in a more dangerous situation
right putting them in a cell alone with
their what sort of like boot laces or
something right they're like do it yeah
they're essentially yeah and then
whenever and then whenever somebody
follows through with it they're just
like oh well we didn't know and you know
the camera is more wrong
yeah it's it's just it's just extremely
dark wow they really see you as some
other things i would imagine not humans
yeah and i think i mean that it's kind
of what society's taught us right yeah
because like
a lot you know it's the law and order
effect right in my mind um because like
we have this very pop culture
understanding of of of
of the the justice system right um which
is you know uh a crime takes place
um an offender or a suspect is is
arrested
um a prosecutor uh builds a case with
the detectives or or the officers or
whatever and then it goes to trial
uh and then there's a long there's sort
of a trial process which never really
actually happens with plea deals
and then there then after the trial
there you know somebody goes to you know
somebody goes to jail and that's the end
of the story right you know it's like
it's it's that's the other story but for
that person typically they that's not
the end of the story it's years and
years and years of of the rest of their
lives
people grow people change people people
really do change and it doesn't take
that long it takes maybe you know
especially especially if you're in your
20s it doesn't you know it's five you
know five years so you're twenty for a
long time yeah yeah in terms of like of
your of your personality and you're sort
of sort of changing so you would you
know i i've seen this a lot where you
know some somebody somebody who is like
a terrible person will like become like
a really
like
stable
you know reasonable person like within a
within within a three to four year
period of time right and so um we have
we sort of forget that about p people
because of this pop culture thing uh and
and it's and even
even with like justice reform advocates
i have this problem because like they're
very focused on like the the the app the
scene um police brutality type stuff
right you know which is which is awful
right you know it's like murdering it's
like murdering of people murdering of
houseless people um the abuse of people
um not taking you know not taking people
of color or immigrants at their word
whenever they say that they've been
abused or they've been harassed or that
you know that that uh that they've been
falsely accused of something you know
like there's a lot of criminal justice
aspects focused on that but they forget
that like that's that we have two
million people and we have like well i
think it's what over two million
uh yeah it's like 25 of the world's
prison populations in the united states
and you know
often voiceless often not unseen often
forgotten about even by people who
really do care and really really do want
to focus on these issues because of just
sort of the way we've sort of focused on
stuff
because we focus on stuff because we can
see whenever there's police brutality
that happens on a cell phone camera we
can see when that happens but when it ha
when it happens in prison there's no
cell phone
yeah i think the prison system is one of
the most
in america and now it's one of the
biggest uh
problems we have as a society i mean the
way that it's privately owned yeah that
there's a vet um financial interest and
keeping people in prison for as long as
possible absolutely and also there's a
profit motive so like the conditions are
going to be horrible yeah the prison
industrial complex it's just a it's a
[ __ ] nightmare it's really is yeah
and like non-violent offenders in prison
i mean it's just [ __ ] horrible yeah
it's hard to bridge that gap when you
don't get to see what goes on there yeah
exactly and then you know how do you go
to battle over something you don't and
as much as i have solidarity with people
like i i remember 2020 with george floyd
with the with the george yeah protest
and um briana taylor protest like yeah
you know i've you know i felt this
affinity and the solidarity with with
them but like it's it's also it's also
don't forget about people in prison
because we don't have cameras in prison
we can't take our own cell phone photos
we or videos we you know this stuff
happens the revolution i've seen this
stuff with my own eyes
you have to believe me that this
happened
it seems also that people are just
getting do you think in general people
are getting over sentenced they're going
to prison for too long you said that you
could change in five years yeah i think
i mean 35 years is insane almost for any
crime do you yeah i oh yeah my i'm a
very different person than i was at 20
very different yeah i mean 22 you're
still a kid yeah in all honesty you know
yeah i when i came out of prison i was
like i was like oh yeah i'm like way
different you still have a chance
to like you still have a chance to also
build a life i feel like where if you
are
released after 35 years yeah what
happens with you then i mean you know
it's the end of joshua institutionalized
redemption right yeah characters who
like
i'm not gonna lie i when i
the first time that i was
hurt that i heard about that i was
getting out of prison i was actually
scared
that was your first reaction um it
wasn't my first reaction but like there
was a couple days when i started to
absorb that this is a possibility and i
was like
i i don't know like i'm scared because i
what's changed what's different you know
what um
you know it was like an overwhelming
thought and this was only after seven
years right imagine somebody who's
who
who's never held the cell phone before
yeah yeah yeah yeah you know who's spent
30 40 years in prison i mean you know i
and you know what i've i've now had a
chance to meet people that have spent
many decades in prison and be released
and they are you know after a couple
years they're the the adapted the
adaptiveness of humans is pretty
incredible but the the fear
and the anxiety that comes with being
released from prison for the first time
is is very real and it's very and it
sticks with you for a while it lingers
you know um and and i you know and i'm
still in therapy you know for for uh
dealing with institutionalization i'm
still in therapy for sort of dealing
with the consequences of spending uh
such a such a large amount of time in
like a hostile and institutional
environment so yeah you know it's very
much it's very much still a part of my
you know um the difficulty that i have
with you know developing you know
long-term relationships and friendships
and things because you know like
you know both both both in prison and
and uh and and in the military you know
like i knew who had my back and i knew
what tomorrow brought and now out here
i don't
i don't know who to trust and i don't
know if somebody's putting on a front
because i'm not with them 14 hours a day
like you know uh and i don't know if
they have my back i don't know who who's
who's like i know the the prison guard's
gonna be unfriendly but i know that like
that this group of inmates here is gonna
have my back or whatever and i don't
have that out here i'm not sure
quite how far people are gonna you know
look out for me or who's gonna be like
uh out and against me in a few in a few
weeks or a few months and i don't know
what tomorrow brings you know i'm i'm
switching from time zone to time zone
i'm going from city to city i whereas
like i was i always knew i was going to
be in in in oscar 227 right myself oscar
237 an oscar housing unit right for you
know years
were you you're out are you kind of
living as a trans person in prison were
the were the guards and the uh prisoners
accepting of that as well
um i would say the inmates are pretty
accepting uh
i think the prison guards were i think
the prison guards were a little weirded
out by it but they got used to it but um
i'm i'm
i think i'm just like a force of will
like i'm just like a force of energy
like in terms of my personality so i i
really
you know i i'm very sociable and i'm
really like engaged with people and i'm
very extroverted so i i just got to you
know like if i encountered somebody who
you know had reservations or hesitations
about it i would just like just be like
all right let's play some basketball or
something like
like just see how i am like you know
judge for yourself that's very
interesting though it seems like
throughout your military and prison
experience where you would expect people
to be kind of more traditional or
masculine that they were accepting of
either your
gayness or your transness yeah i think i
think that the i think that military
people at least in that time frame get a
bit of a bad rap you know in terms of
like that's very that's encouraging yeah
i mean or maybe i'm just so
or maybe i'm just so skewed in my
mentality that i just i that i see you
know
that i haven't really encountered it you
know or i don't see it as much because
like you know like i i but yeah like
when i see it happen to somebody else
though i get oh i get defensive yeah
yeah yeah but i i i think that i'm not
as nearly i i don't nearly take things
as personally and and i try to you know
if somebody if somebody's like
transphobic to me um
in pre in a prison environment i want to
be specific like the context here
somebody's transphobic to me i'm just
like okay bring it like like
what's your issue here like i'm i'm very
upfront about it and it doesn't always
work but you usually
usually they start to warm up
uh and they start to be like okay like
you're different you're you know which
is not which is still
an element of transphobia in my mind it
doesn't mean they're not a transphobic
person but i've had to deal with people
like that and you know i i can see that
there's like some ice breaking that
happens because we're in an environment
like that now out here it's a different
story yeah
i want to go back to iraq yeah so
basically how long were you uh working
at that base uh until i guess
like up until you started kind of like
leaking stuff like how long were you
working there uh yeah so i was i think
was january february 2010 uh was the
time frame uh it's all in my testimony
uh which uh i uh i testified to the
things in trial so there's specific
things that i've been told that went
through the government process that i
can say and so i refer people to the
uh 20 30 to the january uh i think was
january 29 2013 uh uh testimony that
does anything outside of that range in
fact in fact i have to go through
government approval okay wow is that
part of so but
because yeah i was i was in i was an
intelligence analyst well what are they
risk what are you risking them just
suing you because you've already yeah i
can get they consume it they could see
here here's the fun part because you've
already gone to jail for like leaking
right but the same non-disclosure
agreement doesn't end so
if if i were to violate it again oh
you're interesting
it doesn't end i see i see it so so it
it ends either it ends either whenever
the us government says uh that you know
that this information has been approved
and it's declassified which we're
getting closer to
um oh really so you could be released
potentially from this nda yeah it will
or somewhat
sometime in my lifetime or or if the
united states dissolves for some reason
one or the other
well
i'll wait i can't wait to talk to you on
that day
i mean oh yeah like
it's gonna be an interesting day i'm
gonna have a lot to say
there's a lot of missing pieces of the
story so so let me just try to ask what
i can
so you're working there
let me ask this a more personal question
what was there something specifically
no that happened where you're like i
i i need to whistle blow
no no no i i think um it was the cog it
was me dealing with the sort of
cognitive dissonance of
me being
i was a puppy right i was like wet
behind the ears kind of very naive
really truly believing my job and my
role mm-hmm
encountering the reality and sort of the
you know having a you know
like it's like training day right you
know you sort of right right you know
like denzel washington like pulls you
aside and you know
and walks you through this crack yeah
exactly
you know like smoke this pcp right yeah
and like that that was like that was the
gradual process that i went through
which was like okay like here's a
reality here the on the ground reality
and what you've been told are completely
different and and i felt
you know i i felt i felt upset i felt
you felt like maybe misled oh yeah i
felt i felt very misled you know i felt
very misled by by by media by our
institutions
you know by our political i bet a lot of
soldiers feel that
uh you know i i don't i'm not i'm not
gonna speak for i'm not gonna speak for
for a lot of veterans but you know like
i i certainly have encountered friends
and people that i know that one second
we lost power are we still live yeah oh
cause the tv went out yeah
and the ac yeah at the same time yeah
yeah
no sometimes our powers sometimes
explode too much ac season
okay but we're still live dan
so coming they're coming so there was
was there like a growing kind of
resentment just over time when you're
like this is i don't know i wouldn't say
resentment i would say i mean like the
the institutions that i've that i've
that i felt the the most
that i cared about the most that i lost
a lot of faith in um especially because
like i first went to the washington post
new york times you know everybody
everybody knows the the big w word um
but you know those are not not my first
places um you don't say the w word yeah
you don't even say that word well you
know it's
um
what was that what was that are we dying
are we is america dissolving they are
really coming for us yeah what's that
what was that though for real
wait there's nothing upstairs there's no
upstairs
yeah
they really are coming after you're
saying too much
all right well oh so um all right my
security people are coming
they're actually i see somebody
[Laughter]
you went to the washington post but
media institutions i think i think let
me down the most i i remember i remember
specifically there was like a uh tom
friedman article yes
uh that came out
while during the election iraq he's a
he's an editorial for the new york times
right yeah yeah and he was basically he
basically like
like just
pretended away the last like
seven years of civil conflict of
was that the roof again that was i felt
that boom what is going on guys that
sounded like a potential firework yeah
oh it's the solution of america good
vibes wait fireworks why are you no i
felt that i felt that in my thing
that's a good indication that the
vibrations are coming from the ground so
just ahead oh you're sweating on your
feet yeah i felt in my feet so
why aren't people going
someone looked outside and said yeah
look outside
is this a dress public
what no no no
no it's not we're not this is not
horrible
[Laughter]
no no no we've never had any issues with
yeah
yeah but i was interested so you so go
ahead about thomas freeman i was a
captive i'm curious did you finish your
term or was this happening wow yeah i
was in jail for a long time so i yeah i
basically i basically finished uh i
finished up to the
i was i was in the it was in the ending
part of my enlistment okay um but that
got extended by prison got it so what
was it that thomas friedman wrote
thomas freeman wrote an article about um
sort of oh i guess it you know and we
have there are free and fair elections
in iraq now
which is a question mark uh on the
ground um
and uh that this has made the ira the
iraq invasion justified even though the
wmd stuff you know which i don't really
have a huge opinion on on like anything
up to like
2004 i don't really have strong opinion
on because i didn't i actually don't
know anything
prior to 2004 um
in terms of like all of that um
all the discussion um and i was in high
school i was in middle school high
school at the time so um but you know my
understanding of sort of the uh the the
insurgency and the counter insurgency
and how that played out was this
brutal um
you know it was like there was an ethnic
cleansing going on
between you know um sunnis and shias
there's sort of like a
um
a ratcheting up of of um political
rhetoric uh across the political
spectrum in in iraq um it was looked the
other way we uh the united states
government essentially picked aside and
said okay like these people are more
likely to win
they might not be better they might not
be more democratic but um and they might
be using author autocratic means and
methods to win but we're going to back
them because they
serve our security so can i ask you this
is the kind of stuff that was on your
mind during your service yeah i see i
think so because you know like you know
i
we were going there to stabilize to help
i mean this country was [ __ ] up yes
because of us yes
and we were making it worse and i mean
you had a front seat to that more more
than yeah and then and then when i was
like well what we're doing is not really
helpful you know and you know and then
you get told like well that's not you're
that's not you need to decide and you
have thomas friedman writing [ __ ] like
that yeah and basically because you know
he's doing propaganda manufactured
consent at home and you know and yeah i
was like i was like i well one one of
the advantages to having all this stuff
be out there um
and in the in the way that it's that
that is that it is out there is that you
can't take it away
it's true it is reality
take it or leave it
this is what this is what actually
happened it was it was a brutal ugly
war yeah so we we did you know like what
like you know we we did some pretty
awful stuff and and on a scale of
decimation and destruction that um that
uh you know that even to this day is is
is very rarely discussed or don't they
estimate that like 500 000 iraqi
civilians
i don't think we'll ever know it's it's
insane
it's insane yeah the amount of damage
you know we did into that yeah all right
and now and now you know well just
wonder why because there's
because bro we didn't we
didn't just see it we didn't see we
didn't see iraqis as people you know
right we didn't see them as people we
saw them as like terrorists as as a
problem as people in a location and yeah
and i i yeah it's just
you know it's it's it's dark and it's it
make
yeah you know
i i started to feel increasingly
heartbroken just seeing all the stuff
and feeling and starting because like i
i know that i'm um i'm a very technical
person i'm a stem lord and i'm super
into you know technology and math and
computer science and all these other
things and artificial intelligence and
i'm just doing number crunching right
and i just couldn't do the number
crunching anymore i couldn't you felt
just exhausted
emotionally emotionally
and i just started and i learned so much
about people
and the region and what was going on on
the ground every day that i just and i
was just like you know as i sort of feel
like a connection or an empathy or an
affinity do you feel guilty at all
yeah i feel you know i talk about it
more in my book just for how i feel
about
my role my participation
right yeah
you're like damn i mean
again i was a true believer
yeah when you got there did you did you
ever have time to like befriend locals
during your service there yeah i mean
locals but they're mostly uh iraqi
federal police iraqi army uh the i the
the the if the fp and the ia as we call
them by the way i just gotta say an
estimate for stead this is civilians
these aren't even militants yeah
about two hundred thousand wow
civilians died through iraqi civilians i
mean that's terrific unfathomable yeah
it's true yeah that's right you know and
that and now we're you know like well
and then was pretty devastating for us
so
i don't know
there's one specific video that came out
in the league can i talk about that or
no
um no i will not get into that can i
talk about it without you commenting on
it i would rather okay yeah yeah we're
never mind we're i'm trying to keep out
yeah okay
so but anyway yeah horrific just
horrific horrific disgusting yeah when
you were finding out were you trying to
like
leave the army or talk to people like
option is it no it wasn't really an
option i wasn't thinking about it um i'm
mostly just like thinking about like
you know well i wanted things to run
differently and operate differently and
i tried i tried my best to like do that
in my role in my position as best as i
could i know that people
i know people are often confused about
sort of um
about sort of like you know the the
cognitive dissonance that happens where
you are doing uh
a
an illegal act right
and yet i in my in my mind i'm still in
my mind
trying to do my job
in a way that i've rationalized it and i
and i that's how i was able to really
rationalize this in my brain was like i
was like i tried to do my job i tried to
do my role i tried to do the things that
i that we actually set out to do and
have a standard for and i can't do this
i have a question you worked with like
40 other analysts did were any of these
other people disturbed by the stuff that
you guys were working on or did you feel
uniquely
like no i i i don't i don't feel that
these are that these are concerns that
are unique to me um i
it's only human to see that and be like
yo what the hell is this yeah and you
know and you know it goes it goes back
to the prison card guard conversation we
have before the third the rule of thirds
like right there's the people who try to
do good i mean i would certainly put
myself in that camp um and there's which
is a low and that's a high attrition
rate that's a high turnover rate yeah
because if you care too much i think you
just can't survive yeah and then there's
the then there's the you know the the
people who don't care on this statistic
you know people so in that job you feel
like if you're sadistic you can do like
a lot of harm i think i think lesto um
in the in sort of the the soldier role
in the soldier role of being an analyst
i i don't think that you you have that
much of an opportunity to do that i
think that door kickers uh had more of
an opportunity but you know i
i um
i you know the as awful thing as things
were in in iraq and afghanistan um with
with u.s soldiers uh and is as striking
as it is you know i i'm i'm i'm i'm
still appalled and shocked at just what
you know police do in the united states
what they get away with you know it's
just it's just shocking amounts of
of violence and um and you know and uh
it all it all comes together in my mind
you know i don't i don't see what
happened i don't see what happened in
2020 as like being different from what
happened in iraq in 2009 2010 like i
just don't i i see a common thread which
is the militarization of you know um uh
you know some people call it the
boomerang effect where you know you go
out and you do these foreign uh
occupations and you do the
you do an imperialism and then you
eventually they come home and then you
bring that mentality home with your with
your soldiers with your soldiers turning
into cops turning into you know your
judges turning into your politicians
and you just bring this sort of um
counter-insurgency mindset home where
you know cops you know will roll through
a neighborhood of you know of of uh
people of color and they'll they'll view
it in the same way that as as the
soldiers were in iraq and afghanistan
like rolling through a neighborhood like
looking for the enemy
that's interesting it's like the cost of
fighting this unjust yeah bloody war
that's that's so sorry to blackpill you
some more no this is great i mean this
is the stuff that i really want to
discuss with you yeah you know
i think i was saying earlier uh
you know i wore i wore the i wore the
all black because i heard you were black
people yeah the last episode with this
song i heard you that i was black but
yeah i was feeling particularly black i
wanna i wanna i wanna make you feel
better if i can which is that i i'm
actually optimistic you are i am not
optimistic and the reason why i say that
in a dark time is not it's not it's not
copium i swear it's not opium i swear
it's not copium but um i you know i have
seen like in 2000 in 2010
when i went to prison
um
there wasn't a lot of political activism
particularly with progressives and on
the left um
then it was occupy which turned into
you know uh protest movements in
ferguson which turn into you know uh
counter you know like uh resistance
against the trump administration and uh
you know ice and charlottesville which
turned into the george floyd protests of
2020. so i i am seeing a groundswell of
activism awareness education people
talking about these things
on trans issues in particular i've also
seen a lot of progress listen i think
the people care yeah and that's great i
think the people of america are on whole
were were on the right like the people
care about the right things genuinely
yeah but the government is so
functionally uh [ __ ]
like i mean just look at well anyway i
don't i'm not trying to stay uh
blackfield i [ __ ] about this stuff i'm
i'm optimistic yeah i actually think i
actually think people well i think
enough old people are going to die off
in the next like i mean genuinely like
you look at [ __ ] don't get me wrong
and not by me by the way not by me
i mean they're going to die of natural
causes not by me right just to be clear
but like there's a lot of really old
[ __ ] people in congress that just
need to die of natural causes stop in
minecraft i'm serious i know but i'm not
threatening them i'm just saying yeah
yeah yeah they need to [ __ ] die oh uh
i think i think i think they would find
another way to say it
i i what's their name i think
what's her name the 98 year old he's
[ __ ]
they don't retire dan they never retire
they cling to power
no what does it matter they're gonna die
that's life
speaking of i think i think we got we
got something for you really oh you
brought me something uh somebody brought
this to you they asked me what is that
to ethan some sketchy guy yeah from the
and what does that say and
hey national oh i see you spelled it out
from the nra this is from the nra
[Laughter]
i don't know
let's find out no
wires coming all right so wow the nra
brought me something great yeah thank
you
oh it's just cleaning
tears
yeah
like your liberal here
[Music]
yeah yeah you know like you got it
because yeah you know
you know i mean you i mean that but be
it seriously you are truly a victim of
cancelled culture and i want to be
here actually thank you i don't know why
i don't know why they are
i mean you hassan i don't know why like
all these people who
ran and speak about freeze peach and
frozen peaches all the time
you know like why is it that whenever
somebody says something that they have
to get all up in arms like why why do
they have to cry about it
right
who are we talking about the republicans
or because i get canceled by everyone
just the right yeah specifically the
right no but they are the they are the
biggest counselors of all like i mean
the fact that they even get to own this
conversation about um they dominate all
the conversations it's just ridiculous
yeah but so i actually i have i have
more questions okay all right because
i'm i'm i'm captivated by your story
you know i find my story boring
really yeah because my story i'm just
like i don't know i don't know well i
mean you have one of the most unique
life experiences of anyone in modern
time
yeah oops you do
so let's say
so you sent
your stuff to the new york times and
washington post and well i tried to i
tried and as i understand it they
ignored you they did they were your
first people you reached what was that
okay so i want to be clear like uh it's
in my book this is actually it's really
complicated so it wasn't i was ignored
so much as it was it was sort of a
complication with sort of the discussion
of how to do it safely to how to do it
securely i see they were too it was too
hot for them you think no i just think
that they i
boomers right mm-hmm you know like hey
like this is what you're talking about
this is digital stuff you're talking
specifically about getting data to them
right so like this is 20 this is 2010.
this is like january 2010 and these are
people who like struggled to like open
their email okay right i think that's
what was going on it's just incredible
that they missed that well that's that's
why they've changed that's why
i mean one of the things that happened
that is that both in 2010 and in 2013
there was sort of like an oh [ __ ] moment
like oh we need to modernize our
our uh methods and our and you know and
and sort of like how we collect
information how we how we deal with this
stuff and it's actually funny because
you know um you actually get asked this
a lot they're like oh well you know you
you one of the things you want to talk
about is government is government
secrecy right and i'm just like well no
because like that was like a 2010 issue
right now we have now we're so awash in
information and that there's
they just will publish the awful things
that they're doing and it gets drowned
out by misinformation and disinformation
and and people questioning like what
reality is like you know that's the
biggest problem now is there's like
identifying what is real because what
should we care about people people are
living in like completely different
realities even though they're like
living right next to each other yeah
yeah
so were you kind of like
disillusioned by the fact you're like i
have this thing and these the biggest
papers in the world that i want to get
this to are incapable of receiving it i
mean was that frustrating was it
shocking i mean yeah i mean yeah it
would have been not it would have been
nice it would have been nice to you know
like
have uh have a dan ellsberg you know you
know like uh you know meeting in a hotel
room kind of thing but you know like
alas this is not how things played out
you know mm-hmm and and let's just say
and i'm you know i'm you know i gotta i
got a book coming out
dude you're asking a lot of questions
this is good this is this publicity this
is going to get people interested to buy
the book yeah you to you in my opinion
you talking about whatever
is only get people more interested in
the book
well they're gonna have to buy it to get
it um i don't know if it's free if it's
pre-sale yet oh if it's pre-sale i need
to talk to my public system figure out
but
as these as the
things were being disseminated around
the world and there was shock around the
world well i didn't know about this
you'd ha i was in social confinement and
i was like in like a cage in oh so you
were waiting
for like 59 days you were arrested by
the time this became news by the time
this became news i was arrested i was
incarcerated and i had no idea so you
didn't even get to see
that whatever whatever you were being
busted for had meant anything i didn't
even know that they closed off up and uh
the deep deep water horizon uh spill
that was open when you went yeah
i didn't even know until months later so
that was okay so i'm a big i'm a big
soccer fan i love the world cup and the
world cup happened and i had no idea who
played who won anything no scores or
anything so it was someone you
befriended snitched on you basically um
yeah i'm not gonna talk i'm not gonna
talk about that um
that again there's court records so
let's just say this let's skip all that
and then i'm curious so so you get
arrested right you have no idea that
anything you did gets out to the world
yeah you put in solitary confinement
what is that like what is solitary
confinement uh it's boring
okay so uh you know i often get asked
like you know what style confinement
like and i'm like well well like uh go
into your bathroom take all this stuff
out and close the door and then put a
bed in there and then that's your some
people say that's torture what would you
say
um i'm careful with the word torture
because you know for me it has a very
legal implication um
what about like cruel and unusual i
think i think that it is i i think it is
cruel punishment i think it is i i think
that it's definitely not unusual it's
not unusual it's very it's very
difficult there's 60 000 people that
deal with it every day i think that it
is unlaw i i think that according to
international law it is
unlawful after 15 days i think that the
practice should be banned i
i i'm skeptical of prisons in general
and i'm you know
and i never thought i would have this
kind of position where i would be like a
skeptic of prisons but yeah as somebody
who's been through prison and seen the
system like i just don't see the value
in it it doesn't do anything it doesn't
really
no it does it does do something it
controls it controls large populations
it doesn't have anything to do with
individuals like everybody talks about
like oh well this is about individual
responsibility right but it's actually
no it's about collective sort of control
of larger populations that's why it's
immigrant populations and and this isn't
even just the united states it's like
it's like if you look at new zealand for
instance right the native population in
new zealand the native population in
canada are the are some of the highest
you know have the some of the highest
incarceration rates you know it's people
of color in the united states it's
immigrants in the united states you know
the cultural system like imprisons like
people who you know who who like have
who are in there for petty offenses and
just can't pay pay their way out right
it's not it the intentionality of it is
not
it's not about individual
responsibility it's not about crime it's
not about any of these things
rehabilitation it's about controlling an
unwanted population i see that's the way
i view it
so you were in you were in solitary for
how long
i don't have the exact count off top my
head but it was
over a year i think all together a year
over year not consecutively
consecutively was 11 months
yeah and so you're in and so this it's
the size of a bathroom just a bit big
enough for a bed to fit yeah and then 59
days of that we're in a
steel cage in kuwait
and so do you have a bed in this steel
cage what is this yeah it was a mattress
there was a mattress and anything else
but a mattress i don't remember it was
just remember sandy it was really really
there was sand in your in your cell well
yeah cause it was a tent was it a tent
with a cage inside of is it hot as [ __ ]
in there
uh the air conditioner sometimes didn't
work it was usually the ambient
temperature i would say was around 85 to
90 degrees just all the time fahrenheit
that's uh like 30 30 to 40 degrees for
all you europeans out there so it's a
cage with a bed in it yes
and when you say cage there's no privacy
no there's no private uh uh the the
entire time that i was in some drinking
confinement i was being watched
by at least two people wow and what
about like going potty
yeah just go for it that's like prison
life though because there's there's just
in prison yeah you just have a toilet is
there a toilet yeah sometimes i forget
to close the door before i go to the
bathroom my apartment and whenever i
have a friend over there they're like oh
you're lucky you're used to that oh darn
i'm sorry yeah
interesting yeah
well you kind of gloss over that but it
really seems like horrific i mean i mean
almost a year it is it is the way that i
it is a coping mechanism right you know
it's it's just like it's just like you
know like i had this thing happen to me
and like you know my brain and my body
are still trying to grapple with that
and the easiest way to do that it's just
like it's just like chugging on did you
have books or something in there oh yeah
i read thousands of them okay i i i
don't know the number but it's at least
a thousand books
wow uh i yeah
again i i've read a lot i started with
like classics too like american classics
and like historical classics and fiction
non and then like non-fiction and i
would keep up with like news and
newspapers and stuff i read a lot of
periodicals because they were still
printing things back then
um
and so yeah i kept up with a lot of news
and information and
and reading uh an enormous amount of
fictional that like did you learn to
love reading or was it just i've always
loved reading but i actually had time to
do it and uh and you know i was able to
for a while
right yeah my
prison is a prison was uh definitely a
time of still a time of learning and
growth for me personally
what was the food like when you're in a
prison a solitary cage in hawaii can i
be on so
kuwait was awful um because you know
it's field it was like field stuff it
was the same stuff we had in iraq
military food yeah uh
uh quantico where i was at for a period
of time for where i was there for nine
months was a marine corps base uh best
food i've ever had really yeah prison
food
the weirdest it's actually a weird fact
because uh they're off their officer
candidate school was right across the
street so it's like where all the
officers become
and become and they're sort of
cafeteria
that's so interesting like like okay
like it wasn't the best food i've ever
had but like the consistency of it being
so good just you know it's like it's
like having a it's like it's like having
a three-star restaurant food like every
day yeah like wow
but uh but yeah then and then uh the you
know u.s disciplinary barracks and
kansas um and the the you know so prison
system the rest of prison system was
pretty typical um sodexo type stuff your
your your your uh your standard uh um
you know slop on a tray
macaroni and cheese and maybe
maybe maybe you know maybe chicken wings
here and there like i've i'm i'm trying
to eat more pla plant-based but i
i have i have a really soft spot for for
buffalo wings the chicken wings
who doesn't who doesn't it's a huge so
coming out of solitary for close to a
year was it shocking for you yes to get
out of that i needed a recovery period
um it took me months to be able to
interact with people again because you
didn't talk to anyone during that time i
would imagine or uh yeah so the pre i i
did interact with prison guards um but
it was mostly just like deliver food uh
legal appointments i
interact i started to interact more and
more with lawyers at the time
because we were obviously trying to
collect evidence and build a case and
defend ourselves and make our case to
court marshall
but yeah like my my time was barely
isolated
and so does time like become just a
completely abstract
thing or
yeah i you know time
uh i've learned a value time i think
that one of the most important things
that i've learned
uh in my life experience for now is that
i care far more about time than i do
about money
like if
if it's a waste of time like if you were
if you told me that i was gonna get um
100 million dollars
but it was like gonna take a huge chunk
of my time away
i wouldn't change i wouldn't exchange i
would want to do what i want to do with
my time yeah um
i i i value time because you know my
like
as a as awful as our sort of you know
capitalist uh money-based uh
world and structure of society is um and
sort of the race of things is um i've
really learned the value of of time
uh and how it you know we are slowly
dying like we're all slowly dying over
time uh and uh and that time is valuable
and having that time taken away and then
being given back to me has just made me
value every second so much more
and
you know and and i don't want to do
things and you know like i i want when i
when i spend time especially with my
best friend um you know and we just
watch anime or whatever
and you know she often asks me like why
do you like why do you want to hang out
with me and spend time with me and i'm
like because this is what i care about
this is what i value i value the time
together this is so important to me
because i you know i i wouldn't give
this away for anything else because like
we're
you know yeah you got a second lease on
life yeah absolutely and i
really have an understanding of how
precious that time is and how precious
life is and how precious
you know relationships are too because
the relationships i had in prison were
about very learning how to interact with
people and have meaningful relationships
with people was was so important um and
i always recommend this to people you
know like if you know people often ask
like oh you know like what should i do
about you know people who are in prison
or whatever and i'm like write to them
write to them
pick up the phone call when they call
you send them a little bit of money
have some interaction with or or be out
there in the outside world because i've
seen so many people be forgotten about
in the prison system well
it's it's it's
it it sending a letter to an inmate
especially an inmate who's been in for a
significant chunk of time can be a
life-changing experience for them
it changes their entire outlook on life
well
that's really interesting
so what was your transition period like
when you came out of solitary
um
again in my book uh
but uh
yeah i really enjoyed it um i really
enjoyed being able to like be outside of
the prison or be outside of or be
outside
yeah by yourself um
so
uh
i started to run
it was one of the first things that i
did was i started running again um i was
interacting with general population
again
um it was a little slow in terms of like
getting used to talking to people this
was a little private at first uh and
then i and then you know and then i got
sucked into dnd and
playing
playing board games and and i got you
know one of the things that that that is
an invaluable skill from being in jail
is i'm really good at poker in spades oh
yeah
i i for some reason it surprised me just
to see think of prisoners playing d and
d yeah
well i mean it's an escape
it is yeah i mean by definition right
role playing game yeah
so you know um
oh yeah i dm i have a couple campaigns
on standby
so let me just fast forward kind of to
you were in jail for seven years and
those seven years whatever
it comes down
um
you know by the way there's are you
following a lot of the media that's
happening because people are talking
about you during that time there's
people not really my stuff but almost
certainly the rest of the world i was
paying attention to there was a lot of
advocates saying i tend not to read
anything about myself it helps me yeah
no i totally understand that yeah
but there was a lot of people saying
like uh she's being mistreated she's
being tortured it's a human's right
violation
everybody in that system is
right
i guess they thought that what was
happening to you was particularly well
um i would say that the soldier
confinement in quantico and in
um
and in kuwait were documentedly like
inhumane or
found to be like by by third parties and
and outside sources including the united
nations to be you know to be improper um
now the rest of my confinement
you know um
was no different than i guess they
thought that it was just making like an
example out of you
uh overly uh i don't know um
you know i i mean i speculate a little
bit on in my book
there we go again it's gonna dude when
that comes out we're gonna promote it
we're gonna sell so many of those books
i promise
yeah well if it ever comes out if it
ever comes out cause i've i've done i
i've gone on tv and talked about it
before already so but you know when you
fir when your trial came up one of the
charges against you
was um
aiding the enemy which carries a death
sentence yeah well uh i'm guessing that
they decided not to go with death ends
because they went with life they went
for what they shot for life without
parole yeah
which you know is i mean how that
differs in my mind space to 35 years is
mentally different what's what the
difference but um in in terms of like
your ability to access parole and or
early release things like that um has a
significant difference um but yeah they
really they really harped on that um and
it was scary it was
a scary precedent it would have been a
scary president for a lot just to kill a
whistleblower i mean no no not even that
it's because like
aiding the enemy is strange in the
military system because it's the one
offense that you don't have to be in the
military to be charged with by the
military interesting
a civilian can be charged for that yes
interesting yeah the military can come
in and grab you with that but typically
you'll reserve for wartime so i i'm not
i'm not a lawyer in this area it's
really complicated there are a lot of
people really scared about it um and the
aclu and a bunch of other like
a bunch of news organizations were like
super nervous about it um it didn't pan
out i got acquitted
like of that one i got acquitted of that
because you were charged for like 21
things found guilty yeah i mean
yeah it's like whatever but um but yeah
you know like were you scared of that
charge though it must have been
terrifying to be facing that down in the
beginning yeah i mean like i i think i
think i was just like well whatever
comes comes you know and i had this
mindset the whole time
you know i
i am willing to accept responsibility
i
i know when i i you know i like i i made
a decision you know did i understand the
consequences
oh god no
nobody had ever gotten prison for this
before interesting right nobody ever
gone to jail for a significant nobody
ever like my entire life experience was
completely unexpected with this um
didn't you know didn't i i expected to
lose my job lose my security clearance
basically you didn't expect it would be
such a big deal no i did not i did not
fully
grasp how far that they would go or how
significant this would be
but did you know what you were doing was
significant would be significant for the
world i i you know i honestly i i was i
was a little i was going through a bit
of a dark period where i was just like
especially after the new york times in
washington post struggling with them i
was like is anybody gonna care you were
like is this does this even matter do
people even care yeah i can totally get
that yeah and if two biggest papers are
like we can't do this you're like well
maybe it's not that interesting and i
see this every day right and i see this
whole this this horror
playing out
in
my with my own two eyes and in the the
sort of this i understand the statistics
and i know what's going on you know with
with the the data of what's going on and
the reporting and everything else so i
understand the stuff fully and it's just
like how
how is this
like like like how like how can how can
i how can i how can i share this with
people how can i get people to
understand the gravity of this and i was
very worried that and i still to this
day like there's a darker part of me
that often wonders like how much people
really seem to care about awful things
happening in the world you know i'm you
know like seeing seeing the last decade
sort of pan out here in the us and after
kovid and seeing you know the sort of
people not caring about the pandemic and
things like that is is really alarming
for me you know just sort of the
callousness and the carelessness um that
is
that you know because like
you know uh
when we're presented with the truth and
we're we're presented with evidence of
of something happening you know our
propensity to to ignore that or to
pretend it away or to argue away is is
quite frightening quite disturbing and
uh
and and that that that's been a
consistent sort of
sense or a feeling that i've had which
is you know like do people care
i think people care i care i think
people do care i think part of the
problem today is that the propaganda
machines have become
so
effective that people
just
don't know
they know they know it's really they
can't accept it as real because they
there's like a whole propaganda machine
on the right that's saying this shit's
this is all [ __ ] and then you go and
you don't want to believe it right it's
it's a difficult truth yeah you say yo
my government killed 200 000 people in
iraq
and so it's much easier to be like oh
they deserved it yeah tucker's telling
me the truth it's all [ __ ] that's a
relief you know yeah they don't have to
care about it so i think there's just
this really powerful propaganda machine
that it's not just the right yeah
you know the center left the the the
centrists the democrats you know like
this is busy bite
though the thing that scares me the most
is whenever whenever there's
bipartisanship in congress because it's
usually that they're bipartisan not for
a good reason right it's usually over
something really scary and that people
are just going to like look the other
way like you know like we're going to
like give we're going to give
we're going to give local police forces
like stinger missiles
then you look at the votes and it's just
like 435 yeah
you're just like it's just
members of congress and and you know
like set like like 96 senators you know
it's just it's it's always alarming to
me like bipartisanship that's true is
scary to me often because it's usually
some of the worst things are bipartisan
patriot act perfect example yeah pure
bipartisanship
yeah it's incredible isn't it yeah
it was ever a point where you regretted
doing what you did you're like this was
not worth it you know i mean i i just
couldn't play out anywhere other way
like i one of the things that one of the
things that gets me is that i i don't
replay the stuff i don't you know i i i
live in the moment and i and i and i
live thinking of of the future i don't i
don't try to i don't try to i don't try
to relive stuff or relitigate stuff or
or because like what happened happened
and i can't change that and uh you know
and you know i guess some people they
wanna they wanna sort of like
question or or or or think of different
things and it was just like it was just
that my experience and i i go through
again this is in the book you know but
that experience like played out in such
a in such a meandering
freak of nature way like you know
such as such a freak of circumstances
way
um that uh i you know
both both good and bad like i just i
don't you know it was like it's like
like a statistical error margin of like
probabilities that right the set of
events could have happened in this
particular way and any little thing
could have if anything had changed in
any at any and any particular point you
know if i if i decided to go um uh take
up a certain offer and go to a different
position
i wouldn't have been there um if the if
our unit hadn't been deployed redeployed
from afghanistan to iraq you know whoop
you know well you know history would
have played out very differently
and my role would have been very
differently i mean i had to be in a
specific office in a specific in a
specific time frame that had specific
access to things and then have a
specific like you know like everything
was just extremely
extremely specific so i don't try to
i don't try to rehash those decisions
because i'm like i had i made all these
decisions that i could do with the
information that i had
available to me at the time and the
options that i had available to me at
the time and
what what more can you do
um it is pretty incredible though i
think even throughout it you did have a
lot of even though there was a lot of
like hate for you they're within like
certain political i haven't really
encountered a lot but there was a lot of
really a lot of support like i think you
must have had some really good lawyers
that came to your defense right probe
like and i mean you sure you know i have
i have lawyers but i mean they cost me
money you can't did you have to you
can't do a pro you cannot do a scale you
cannot do a case with a scale problem
but then how do you how
raise money my family raise money um
yeah i i certainly have debts that i
still still owe them well i mean like i
saw some but like it's we have a payment
plan so it's like
right there was a big campaign to raise
money for you to pay the lawyer yeah
it's managed yeah it's not it's not it's
not an issue not an issue for me wow
but that's pretty incredible it is
incredible though throughout everything
that you're able to
you know
be free and be living your life yeah
after all of that i mean it is pretty
incredible yeah i'm living a pretty fun
life now yeah i mean obviously you know
we were on lockdowns and and and i
wasn't traveling for a bit but i've i've
been in europe i'm here in la i mean
although i kind of and like being not a
fan of the city
oh that way yeah i get it it's love hate
it's not a great city to visit i'm an
east coaster through and through i knew
i grew up in the midwest but i i i i
love new york
i've fallen in love with if you're a new
yorker la's the worst city
i i can you know because like it's the
antithesis it's yeah we have we at least
have some modicum of public
transportation
yeah nothing here
so everything is so spread out here yeah
yeah
it's a 30 minute drive is short like it
takes us 30 to 40 minutes on a good day
here and we're like seven miles away
yeah
yeah seven miles away is like to jfk in
new york that's like all the way out
there
oh is that right yeah
um
so basically
the big
the big change came for you
when uh president obama
decided after everything to commute your
sentence why do you think he did that
you know i
he said what he said and so
what did he say he uh he said that he
felt that the sentence was was too much
that um
you know i had served my time
and uh you know i i had gone through the
process and gotten through the the court
system
um and uh and you know and then asked
for a commutation which i did um i asked
for you petitioned for that i petitioned
well
the public petition publicly
for time served
we petitioned for 10 years
which is what we were able to do within
our within on our end so we we
we wanted a reduction of sentence from
35 years to 10 years which would have
made me
in the range of eligibility for parole
at that time um but did it feel like a
long shot when you were asking for
commutation oh god yes yeah oh yeah like
um actually
you know i i i i talk about this again
in my book but like we had we sort of
had reasons for why we were doing it but
they were like to
to
improve my quality of life
you know to really
you know just sort of draw attention to
some issues and and raise some long-term
health issues and and you know
healthcare issues with being trans and
whatnot and really drive home sort of
message like you know like you know it's
it's time to start it's time to start
you know taking care of some of these
things especially if i'm going to be in
prison for
you know another 20 plus years um
uh and yeah uh i uh i we we we had no
expectations walking into this yeah yeah
we were
you know uh
it we figured it was a long shot and it
was actually
honestly
i mean
this is a bold decision from obama
because he's the one that he was the
president he got sentenced right yes so
because if you think about it if because
i i never had time to think about this
um
you know this was the last decision that
he made as president is like one of the
largest that's a big thing yeah it's a
legacy but a cap on his presidency sort
of legacy defining decision
you know being a capital sort of like a
legacy defining his decision and you
know and one of those was to give me a
chance
and that's that that's a bull and and
also not only that but like this isn't
like oh we're commuting a 40-year
sentence to a 30-year sentence right it
was yeah this is like this is like no we
are taking
four fifths of your sentence and
slashing it
which is a big deal
i mean i or five is five-sevenths is
what i think it is um and yeah it's a
big deal
it's crazy to think that probably
almost any other president
probably would not have done that yeah
and yeah the that's the thing is like i
i think that it was a it was a bold and
risky it was a it was a bold and rescue
decision that you know sort of
whatever i do for the rest of my life is
going to be tied to his decision so yeah
it was it was a bold decision and i'm
and i'm very aware of that i'm very
aware of sort of the the risk so how do
you feel about uh president obama
you know i i think i think he tried i
think he tried i think he was a
president who
didn't understand the reality
of
the moment that he was in
um
he wanted to reach across the aisle he
wanted you know like
uh health what you know getting health
care was like the capstone of his entire
legacy and he didn't get anything else
done
um he's mostly spent the the presidency
like treading water and whatnot and sort
of um one of the reasons for that and
then the only scene the only seemingly
things that the only bits of his legacy
that he seemed to to be able to keep
were sort of carryovers from the bush
administration and sort of the
solidification the crystallization of
the security apparatus um you know the
the use of the of you know
the the the use of the militarization of
policing in the u.s um obviously he was
uh
he became known as sort of the
deporter-in-chief in that time
i think that i think that he that while
he personally tried i think that
the
the presidency is such a toxic office
it's such a poisonous position because
it's not just a person it's an
institution
you are the executive
of the executive branch of the united
states and the executive branch the
united states acts
you know
you know
acts on behalf of the the of the sort of
like ruling class in the united states
the sort of power is to be within what
you know the moneyed interests of the
united states and so does the congress
and and i think that um that he being
sort of this constitutional lawyer
um you know has tried to wrestle with
this and grapple with this and you know
and then you just had this sort of rise
of power within the reactionary right
where you know went from like because if
you recall you know we went from like
paul ryan being the face of the tea
party to
to what to like josh hawley and you know
and this is the sort of marjorie taylor
greens like you know the right has been
just
surging so far right and just the
overturned window's been getting pushed
further and further to the right and
this is even occurring during his
presidency and he's responding to the
the republicans
and to his his
and to his progressive base the same way
that they were in the 90s right you know
which is like uh progressive base wait
your turn we'll get to these things when
we get to it and then trying to work
across the i o constantly scrambling to
to work with and try to get concessions
from republicans and this is this has
just been the consistent you know like
the the administration has just got
continuation of this yeah
yeah at this point at this at this point
i i think i think that personally he
tried i think that he did that that he
he made that he made a few
that he made a few decisions as an
individual um
in in that and then in that role in that
in the office but just just sort of like
the poison-ness the the poisonedness and
the toxicity of the of the office of the
presidency is
and i've often i i don't know if you've
noted if you've seen this but i've
regularly advocated for the the
abolishment of the presidency as a as a
political office i i don't think that a
single person should be in this role i
don't think that an executive office
should exist i you know i i really think
that that's one of like that's honestly
like you know
that's honestly one of the biggest
failings i think of the constitution is
sort of structuring the system in this
way in which you have a soul you have
this king like
basically we have an elected monarch
that's what we have you know you switch
between the parties or whatnot but you
you basically
you get to pick you who who wears the
crown
every
every few years and and has all the same
powers that um that the crown of the of
that year of the night of the
18th century had right
and uh and so yeah i'm very skeptical of
sort of the the ability of any of any pr
like i don't think i don't think you
just need to elect the right president i
think you that the problem is the office
itself interesting
do you have personal feelings towards
obama as the person who commuted your
sentence like yeah yeah absolutely yeah
i i
you know i i i find it correct you know
because like uh politically obviously we
sort of have some disagreements and and
whatnot but i mean that's a bold
personal decision and i i can't
how can i yeah yeah
he didn't he didn't have to do that yeah
there was just there was no penalty to
pay for him not doing that sure
it was only a risk to him yeah no
benefit really and and and that that
that that that's significant on a
personal level to me there is a there is
a a level of gratitude towards him yes
yeah yeah personally yeah i would say so
yeah i mean that makes sense
so where were you when you this first
broke that you uh had effectively been
that's in the community because you're
asking vignettes for the book now
okay where were you the second after
where no
so well um
i'm assuming you were
obviously you're in jail
and you know i do i do do other stuff
now i do do all this stuff
you know i am i'm a security expert i'm
working in the field of ai now uh i work
on many projects um you know uh and i'm
just getting started you know i'm
starting to do media stuff again
um you know uh sorry to pivot but uh you
know it's just uh you know i i um
one of the things i've been trying to do
for like the last few years is i've been
trying to like oh well what about 2010
or what about president i'm just like
well you know like look around you like
this is a pretty scary time it's a
pretty intense time well let me ask you
about the book then how long have you
been working on it uh well it's been
since 2017.
oh wow yeah and the book ends in 20 and
it ends in 2017.
oh it's just about that year you mean or
no
it's my life story up to 2017. okay i
see i see
and i know that you've been writing it
and right now the book is just being
held for approval from the government no
no no i think we've got approved so oh
you're all approved yeah it's approved
and we'll just need to like actually
publish the book so you just but you do
have a publisher yeah uh
for our stress
i can never pronounce it right fsg so so
this is going to be a huge national
publication i'm assuming yeah i i think
so
you know it's a it's yeah it's not it's
not like verso press or anything have
you ever written a book i mean what was
that experience like for you
really
why yeah i don't recommend it for anyone
oh no
because i'm rehashing and reliving it
was awful
i mean honestly like
there were three drafts that i went
through and i went through and and went
through and it was like there were times
whenever i couldn't look at the screen
because i would have an anxiety attack
looking at the screen i could write a
book about writing the book that's how
intense this process
and i probably will
mostly just from reliving the trauma not
the act of actually writing i'm probably
gonna have to write a book about just
sort of
dealing with the the real with sort of
developing a lot of traumas living
through a traumatic period
period of my life and then
having that be taken away but also like
having the traumas be taken away and
then be like
dragged into a world that where
everything is just sort of like a united
states that is slowly crumbling and the
infrastructure is collapsing
and uh and and you know the the
institutions are failing and you know
there's like attempted coups and uh you
know um uh mass you know mass shootings
that don't lead to any sort of you know
any any kind of uh change or anything
like that you have mass protests the
largest protest movement ever in united
states history not lead to virtually any
change whatsoever yeah you know it's
just like it's just such a
debilitatingly
um exhausting
time period to be a political figure and
to be somebody who cares and is
passionate about activism and politics
and and and and being involved in the
world and be being involved in community
and uh and and to carry this weight of
this time frame and this experience um
and and yeah you know like um it's gonna
be it's going to be uh it's going to
take i mean i i you know i don't know i
don't know i don't know if i'll ever
recover i don't know if i'll ever fully
recover but i'm definitely healing i'm
definitely i mean yeah
i probably wouldn't have been able to
have i probably wouldn't have been able
to have this conversation in this way
and
yeah with you
what was it like working i'm assuming
you worked with editors and stuff like
that yeah was it weird getting notes on
your like personal anecdotes oh and they
always wanted more oh they they say dig
deeper yeah which you know i did
you know i did dig deeper um
within the confines of the law yeah of
course yeah um
because uh i mean the government
obviously got to say um you know we
relented on that we
we had we went through a government
approval process but yeah the the
editorial process was
brutal
brutal
yeah uh i i believe it called my editor
the uh the butcher oh no
but that's good right to have a to have
a brutal did you like your editor or was
it just like uh uh i mean i hated my
editor until until the book was cut and
then i was like this is good and then i
was like i'm satisfied
i see this is this isn't the book that i
envisioned this isn't the book that i
set out to write interesting
um this isn't the book that but it's the
book that i feel comfortable with and
then i can act that i feel comfortable
with and i can say i can put my name on
this
that was that problem so the book is
basically just like on a autobiography
there were times when i was like this
book sucks i was just throwing sheep
really yeah
well to be fair you were doing that with
the with the information you had when
the new york times didn't want it to so
i'm sure the book is going to be amazing
yeah i'm i'm
[Music]
you know i'm just i'm just eager to i'm
very eager to move on with my life yeah
and to like get on to the next stuff
because like i got bigger stuff coming
so what are you working on now yeah
what's what's
uh so i'm working on right now uh
obviously the book is coming out um i
work for uh i work for a
a privacy company now um oh
you work like full time for them uh
i work
or like a freelance thing i'm a
contractor um but i work i essentially
work
uh i i work part-time full-time like
basically full-time hours sometimes and
then part-time hours
um so i am a contractor for a privacy
company called nim um which is uh which
is privacy but uh which is like a
privacy technology like you know tor
you know uh and vpns and things like
that it is a it is it is a forward
thinking technology and sort of looking
forward uh over the next 20 years and
sort of the the needs
of anonymization
and encryption and securing things on on
the internet i actually came up with a
very similar idea in 2016. one of the
reasons why they reached out to me in
2016 was they were trying to get uh they
were trying to get my opinion on it so i
reviewed this white paper and i got
asked to review it and i went through
and i reviewed it and i went through it
and you know i'm not trying to do like a
sales pitch or anything for them uh
right now but uh this is something that
i'm working on and that i
sort of helped uh help help develop and
create um the downside is is that you
know
we're doing cryptography and we're doing
privacy-based technology um in a time
whenever like everybody associates
crypto with like cryptocurrency and
tokens yeah it's crypto in a different
completely different way yeah so it's
more private it's privacy focused there
is a blockchain component to it which is
like the part that makes people cringe
but i'm like well this is
blockchain technology is
like this is not nf this is not scam
nfts this is not you're not nobody's
going to be making bit like this isn't
bitcoin like nobody's going to be
hoarding a ton tons and tons and tons of
this stuff it's simply a a sort of
management system a way of managing sort
of nodes across the network or whatever
to truly decentralize things which you
know i understand the skepticism of that
because i am not a crypto bro i am not
i am not into the stuff whatsoever um so
you know like it's just trying to
educate people about sort of like how
how how cr how cryptographic technology
can work without it burning down the
rainforest uh without it uh without it
sort of like leading to uh a bunch of uh
a bunch of new
um you know uh
crypto bros like buying uh you know big
houses in the hollywood hills right
right and and and you know having cringe
uh having cringed jpegs you know
of course you know like it's it's just
like you know like it's it
the good news is that the crypto crash
has made it easier to sort of like
because it's cleared a lot of the people
who are just like out get really quick
um out of the way and sort of be able to
be like well actually like we i come
from privacy and techno from the privacy
technology space which you know is older
and is where a lot of stuff came from
it's all these grifters who came back
later to try to get rich quick so but we
are sort of operating in the space where
we're you know anytime we talk about
cryptography
or privacy
like people are just like
like are you talking about bitcoin
no yeah
so are you a little bit resentful or
maybe i don't know if that's the right
word but all these people that came out
and kind of just let you describe just
kind of ruined
crypto and the public
you know oh absolutely public sphere oh
absolutely like you said crypto
synonymous with like scam
yes
and
you know that and that's going to be
that's going to continue to be a problem
yeah definitely not like the the crypto
crash i think has cleared a lot of
people but they're like you're just
gonna open things up for the next uh for
the next bear market for the next
quote-unquote bear market step bitcoin's
still at 29 000. yeah but i mean what
was an app before like 50 60 i don't
have any token assets i don't really
mean neither i note that we're token
free
um
well that's great and i know you you
were streaming on twitch you said during
the page i was streaming on twitch but i
have uh the big thing i'm working on
right now is i'm working on a youtube
series oh um i've been working on this
for one and a half years i know that
people are going to be like i've been
paying your patreon for this for this so
what's the project um
i it's a first youtube it's a youtube
series in which i break down advanced
technologies
and sort of discussions about them um
the things that are topical and uh break
them down to a bill nye the science guy
eighth grade level so what's the hold up
if it's episodic um well it's episodic
in terms of like the topic so the first
video is cryptocurrency yeah uh which i
am pretty i'm it may be pretty cryptic
currency a postmortem uh where i just
sort of talk about
and i get into the weeds of how it
actually works because everybody's like
because i the most asked question of
2021 was what is an nfg and what is a
crypt how does cryptocurrency work right
and i was like okay i'm asked this
question so much there's obviously
demand for this and i looked for people
who do try to talk about this stuff and
everybody's talking about the market
everybody's talking about like burning
down of rainforest which all this stuff
is true but nobody's boiling it down to
the most interesting part for me as a as
a technologist which is the math
which is how this like why why is
why is cryptography a basis of this
technology
and i get into that and and sort of how
that connects to science technology so
when can we expect that that sounds
great uh i i've redone filming in
production because i didn't like the
first version
i i i was there yeah i saw the first
version i was like i was like okay
i learned how not to do this and i
learned you know it was a learning
experience for me um but yeah so uh
we're up uh we i'm filming this weekend
in fact okay and in in new york again
i'm back to filming uh filming portions
of it so we're in the production phase
um
uh
and mostly we're just sort of rehashing
on on stuff so i'm thinking that by the
end of summer but um i said that i said
by the end of summer last summer
but we put up we put a pin in it
actually production we put a pin in
production because uh because covid in
late 2021 because it looked like we're
coming out of it
and then and then delta hit or what then
yeah and then omicron and now it's like
crazy again yeah it's crazy again but um
you know it's kind of nuts like
everybody i know yeah
is getting covered like all my family
members all my friends these guys yeah
it's like people aren't really dying but
the long of it is scary yeah it is scary
yeah i mean i i got when i got covered
in 2021 i got um i had i had symptoms
for about two or three months so you had
a little bit of long coved yeah i did um
it was actually funny because like when
i got my when i got the third shot when
i got the booster
december or january of december january
um all those symptoms went away oh wow
oh really that's amazing yeah and then i
got and then like three months later i
got covered again
really just three months later
three months later i got covered again
but it was like by that time it didn't
phase me i like tested positive and i
was like oh wow like the rapid test i'm
positive then i started to feel like a
little a little under the weather but
like it didn't it didn't really knock me
out or anything like it did before so
there's one question that everyone wants
to ask before we wrap this up
and it's what is your favorite anime
that people are wondering oh that's a
good question um because really
i'm i'm actually torn a little bit uh
with my animes um because death note is
very high up there death note is pretty
good but i in my opinion i won't say
overrated yeah i won't say overrated but
yeah i i've rewatched it recently and
i've realized that it fails the bechtel
test enormously which as a trans woman
kind of bothers me oh that where there's
like not enough women in it there's not
enough women in this really they only
talk about they only talk about other
men or whatever yeah when there's a
woman in on the scene they only talk
about other men so it's really
interesting i want to see i want to see
i want to see death note but like with
more
more girl power i want to see an anime
of that variety so death goes pretty
high up there yeah neon evangelion um is
pretty good
um
you know uh i actually revisited gundam
wing
oh wow
i really got it because i watched that
was one of the first animes that i ever
saw um uh then it's actually aged really
well and amazing it does not fail the
bechtel test
so
that's it i mean yeah you have to that's
the 90s like what is the specification
of that test because it's not like it is
really yeah it's actually you have to be
really [ __ ] bad to fail this test and
it's incredible how many things fail
this test how's it called or send me the
rules baby
it's actually really interesting it's
it's incredible how much media actually
fails this
because
when you hear this you'll be shocked
so that's it what about uh one punch man
one punch man oh my god
i haven't seen it you gotta watch that
it's so [ __ ] no i haven't seen it
that's probably i'm not a weeb you're
not a wee but i'm not a weeb but i do
what i do every everyone i don't know my
my my my best friend in the whole wide
world is uh is is a weep she's a weebo
die hard weeb and uh is my source of all
things anime and all sorts like and like
if i if i ask a question she like knows
it she's like on point and i'm just like
oh wow so let me recommend my favorite
is hunter hunter uh-huh you've seen that
one or not yet i have seen that yet okay
did you love it oh i thought it was all
right
you watched the whole thing you saw the
camara ant arc i did
okay all right everyone's a title well i
mean like i'm in a becca okay
yeah
a mecca
there's no mechs in that i know that's
what i don't know you like the mech [ __ ]
okay i like the mech [ __ ] you like
gundam like evangelion like yeah there's
some mechs in one punch
there's a little message there there's a
little bit but you know it's not like
king of the hill
i see people saying
king of the hill
great
uh attack on titan is awesome mike on
titan is great yeah they're like that
shows let's go that show is really good
yeah and then my hero academia is one
that i really like
it's a little it's a little yeah like
i like that show i like it i like it but
i wouldn't put it in that's a bad anime
too recently oh really yeah i'm sure
there's a lot of that yeah there's a lot
of bad anime um i have a crunchyroll
okay
i've been trying to get on crunchyroll
do you know what's so weird
i'm trying to sign up with apple tv and
they're making me sign in through itunes
and i'm like i don't [ __ ] know my
itunes and i really want to get
we tried that didn't we all right i
gotta i gotta put more effort into this
i gotta find the email address
yeah god you talk to me i'm the security
so people are saying it's your birthday
uh is it your birthday my birthday oh i
don't know why people are saying that
december 17th that's not even close oh
couldn't be further away actually pretty
much yeah it's almost exactly six months
away yeah yeah um
okay let me read this test because this
is actually interesting so i just think
i i'm fascinated by you know how close
we are in age though are we the are you
36 i'm 34. oh i'm like
yeah i'm just number 12 by the way so
we're very close why are you fascinated
by how close we are in age i don't know
because i'm about to be 37 so yeah i
look because i look you know like i feel
closer to you than i am to hassan
oh really hassan's like
yeah his songs
are you know what i'm used to everyone
being younger
he's yeah
he's a young man he looks old as [ __ ]
though he's decrepit yeah he looks
beautiful he hunches he's like child
but you know what um
i'm used to everyone being younger than
me
yeah he's a summer child
um so let's see
this test is a measurement of the
represent
representation
of women in fiction yep it asks whether
a work features at least two women who
talk to
each other about something other than a
man wow that's it yep all that has to
happen
is that two women have to talk to each
other about something other than a man
that entire serious death note fails
[Music]
i mean it's insane how many shows
actually failed yeah i know i like i
like just do a running a rough running
estimate when i'm watching these things
now so i pick up on this but so like
when i watch it again like i cuz cause
like i watched it when i was like what
like 16 or 17. no it was 18 because it
came out in like two thousand
it was hanging on like 2007 right so
like i was like young when it came out
i'm actually curious how many
uh
shows fail or movies fail this is can
you find this it's enormous because it's
like it's kind of insane when you see
this the basically anything from the
1990s
a a.b wants to say that attack on titan
uh the women are badass so there you
have it yeah there you go i love attack
on true
give me a list of of notable failures
here it is
all right let's take a look jaeger who's
that babe
um
the list
hey how about you can you guys send me
the link
but can you send me a list of like
notable
uh morbius fails of course you did
morbius fails in every aspect
fantastic beast the secret of dumbledore
not surprising that's incredible
it's just incredible that anything could
fail that top gun maverick fail i don't
think there's even any women in that
movie i haven't seen it though
um all right here i got a list 11
blockbusters
that fail
the bechdel test
let's take a look yo a whole marvel lord
of the rings trilogy the whole trilogy
are you serious what is that but that's
written they went they stuck with the
book and it's true
dude the whole like 11 hours there's
about two or two women having a
conversation about anything but a man
nope that's nice
ratatouille damn you mouse
slump dog millionaire
avatar really avatar
the social network i mean okay
jump street avengers the avengers
that doesn't surprise me yeah it doesn't
surprise me
the grand budapest hotel that surprised
me that is surprising well it's it's
super fascinating yeah i love this stuff
well on that note
well you know what um we didn't feel the
bechtel test today uh
no in fact not you're not even slow yeah
not even close we didn't talk to each
other about just a man
yeah did you guys mention a man to i
don't think so
[Laughter]
so the book is coming out hopefully this
year beginning of next year yeah and we
are going to be standing by very excited
to read it yeah awesome i'm thrilled to
you know actually do something that i've
been working on for five years and we
also look forward to your youtube series
that's coming out yep uh soon right yes
uh the youtube account is xy chelsea uh
it's just
c forwards that i think it's just xy
chelsea on youtube is there anything on
that channel currently no there's
nothing on that channel currently it's
just it's prepared i it's set aside um
i'll publish it and i'll post it i have
a patreon i have a patreon i i'm not
recommending people subscribe to the
patreon right now because i want i don't
really need the budget we already have
the budget for it um
and uh we're gonna
we're gonna wait until we actually put
something out before i start pitching
okay because we raised money and we set
that money aside and that's been being
used for the production project so okay
i've been trying to send emails to
people who have subscribed and i'm just
like no no we're still doing it like
it's still happening yeah yeah we're
just it's just like literally production
problems um yeah is there anything else
you want to plug before we
uh twitter you're on instagram you're
yeah i'm on i'm on twitch uh or i was on
twitch i haven't uh done a twitch stream
since november of last year i will be
streaming again um once uh i probably
probably towards the autumn uh i will be
streaming again because uh
i'm way i'm really just waiting on the
slow down in terms of like my travel
because i've been making up for all of
the travel of the last few years
uh last three years really um
in the last uh three or four months
you know it's crazy i just so your tag
is like xy chelsea right it is yes i
just typed there's like a whole
documentary there's so much media there
was a documentary a showtime documentary
xy chelsea what's the xy i mean uh
that's just my uh that's my chromosomes
baby oh okay yeah but why would they
that's me that's an interesting name for
a documentary they i mean they chose it
because that's my that's that's your
thing that's my twitter handle yeah i
got it
but i gotta get that trademark back it's
kind of is it kind of surreal that
there's like so much media about you
there's like yeah i don't think you can
get documentaries
yeah that's good yeah yeah i i highly
recommend that you know one one of the
worst things that uh that like twitch
streamers youtubers uh twitter
personalities do because they read their
own stuff
yeah you know i yeah it will come to the
same conclusion doom pill because
nobody's ever gonna write the right
thing you're always gonna know that it's
different
um
i'm i live and have happily and bliss uh
i have this is why i have an assistant
who reads the stuff for me good mm-hmm
beautiful that's the way the producer is
like i got you covered
well you know it's such a such a
pleasure and honor to have you it's
great to be here thank you man yeah oh
thank you so much yeah and thank you for
sharing you know all those things and
you're a victim of cancer culture yeah i
want you to know it from the rooftop
say it
thank you
amen let this man go
when will i be let him go off the rails
let me go off the rails
yeah they'll actually you know what's
interesting i've been canceled many
times lost a lot of sponsors
i will say and i guess maybe i shouldn't
be saying this but knock on wood i
didn't lose any from the bomb [ __ ] well
that's because you already lost them i
think yeah well i mean yeah to be fair i
think all of them that we're gonna leave
carlson mode where you've lost everybody
but
i still got my pillow baby
can we get my pillow i wonder if mike
lindell would sponsor it
no i need some mic i need some my pillow
money
yeah where is there a lib version of my
pillow um there is but don't don't look
at it
really oh no now you're gonna look it up
aren't you no but i mean like no like a
super rich dude no chris who's willing
to pay me
no matter what i said it already exists
it's the david hogg's thing
yeah his name is david oh he made the
pillow yeah the lip pillow oh really
yeah he made a lip pill oh god liberal
tears pillow
yeah well you got tissues all right
hopefully hog
can take that big fat hog and sponsor me
yeah right
anyone
cog
thank you
all right well listen
you're going back to new york soon yes i
am uh i'm going back to new york uh
where oh god i don't this is why i have
an assistant yeah love shadow love it
love uh i want to be able to have a job
like you where i sit in one spot yeah um
which i was doing last year um but
lately i've been on travel and i'm going
to be traveling probably until well
until 2023 at this stage so speaking
engagements and stuff like that a lot of
speaking i actually i mean my employ uh
the project i'm working on uh most of
the employees work in europe so that
requires a lot of transatlantic travel
um
uh and uh um that's the nim project and
um i am also um
you know obviously doing media and
filming and things like that yeah a lot
of projects up in the air and then and
then obviously like yeah like basically
i'm just like
like all of these different projects
that i've been working on for like the
last two years are all starting to come
to fruition like in the next six months
that would be good like the video get it
all out dj stuff like i'm gonna start
doing my first dj sets the book is
coming out
um you know uh the the video
uh streaming i'm gonna get back into
streaming all these different things are
all happening all at once which means
that my i have no sleep schedule what's
that
you know i just
there was one thing i wanted to ask you
that i just realized yeah that i forgot
to circle back to
you know i was just really curious how
your dad having
the military man yeah and having done
you know become who you are and what you
did what you did
was that when you guys cut off uh
communication or did you talk to him
after all that happened oh no that's a
different thing it's a different family
issue oh really yeah so the so what was
his reaction to the to the whole leaking
thing
i think it's just the only denial
oh really yeah there's like a cringe
interview like don't look at it
oh you're like
he like said that it wasn't that it was
like impossible for me for dude to do
that or something like that oh he thinks
you're innocent it never happened
well yeah it was like but that was like
in his own it was we like told him not
to and we're like yeah dad wait you know
like we're gonna have
we have a court martial coming up like
don't don't go on tv and say things so
it's been a long time since you talked
to him so i guess you don't really know
what's his opinion about all that i
don't but you know this is why i have my
sister and why i have my aunt so you
know like we keep family i don't want to
get in my family yeah my family like my
family is off limits yeah i understand
you know at the end of the day like at
the end of the day you know as much as
you know i have a falling out with you
know any family member like you know
that that is that we're still
like we're still family
this is it's a total like the reason why
i haven't talked to my dad in a while is
nothing to do with the latest with the
leaks or the or the public stuff it is
completely internal family affairs
interesting okay
i thought there might be a connection
there but no there isn't folks the one
thing i wanted to ask and uh you had to
leave it on that note i know i'm sorry
all right well
we were talking about uh
well you're about to get home yeah or
getting on yeah cause i gotta go
yeah well have a safe flight
good luck with everything yeah very much
looking forward to all the stuff you're
working on thank you for having me and
again
oh thank you so much and thank you for
coming on you should put up and don't be
black pills anymore i'm optimistic if i
can go through everything that i've gone
through and you're and you can live and
you know you can live in los angeles and
and and have this and have this
opportunity to have this show like
there's no reason for you to be doing
built
i'm doing pill i mean just seeing tucker
just being able to see
ted cruz say something colossally stupid
as we need one door and people and p him
not get like
you know somebody who grew up publicly i
mean
who grew up in the midwest the truth
doesn't matter all that matters is that
it owns lips
yeah that's black filling yeah it's so
depressing by the way if you need help
with any youtube stuff let us know
we're we're we're we're great we're
great we're all right
all right i'm gonna put you in
connection with my business yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah we can help you with
whatever you need all right next
all right well thanks everyone for
watching it's friday baby
friday
i hope everyone has a great weekend we
will be back on monday as usual
do we have anything that next week dan
that we're working on
we have a bunch of stuff hold on i had
to figure out where ian's beat switches
uh yes we have a big uh week next week
but um one of it is uh a top secret
project that
is a top secret well don't tell me
that's funny that's really funny
yeah uh all right well just it'll be
next friday's episode though we got
something really big planned for next
friday so look forward to that everybody
thanks guys see on a great weekend
all right thank you
[ __ ] yeah baby
[Music]
to the three
ritual with more
you